[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am Marv Bernard welcome back
ladies and gentlemen to our home as
always here at the scum and villainy
Cantina in a Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands together to the
folks at home know your real ladies and
gentlemen as you can see we are still in
Westeros or Winterfell which kinda still
exists after last night so the bar has
spent a month being very Game of Thrones
themed
this is going away ethic tomorrow
tomorrow this is the last day you can
spend in Winterfell totally man just
like why does the [ __ ] night Kings
coming he's easily beat now we know how
to do it man you just have arias to have
them in the gut spoilers I'm sorry if
you're coming to this show I assume you
all watched it that's it like that that
would be like coming to this show and
not see Avengers endgame as everyone let
me exactly has anyone has anyone not
seen endgame yet just put your hands
together real quick Wow that's well done
kids well done you've done anyone not
who any does anyone who doesn't or
anyone is anyone who does watch Game of
Thrones didn't see Game of Thrones last
night you guys just [ __ ] ruined a
piece of it for you I mean the internet
right like they probably beat me to it
god I feel bad I don't it was two nights
ago
oh yeah right [ __ ] everyone yeah man
it's it's we're gonna we're gonna lose
the look of the bar which is nice we
should appreciate it one last [ __ ]
time and stuff they did a really great
job look look at this yeah give it up
for the folks who did the bar now the
bar gets stripped down to the original
concept of course which is the cantina
just in time for Saturday is May the
fourth so that is this like when JC did
this when he did the Winterfell skin on
the place I was like this is [ __ ]
dope leave it up for the whole run of
the show they only got six episodes and
[ __ ] like that and he said we can't
because May 4th is May the 4th and I was
like yeah I know and they said but have
one job he looked at me as if I was
talking to the Pope and I was like you
don't have to have church on Christmas
like he's like that's our whole [ __ ]
thing man so yeah so they're gonna strip
it right back to cantina and so on
Saturday it's May the fourth and it's
big Star Wars celebration here at the
scum and villainy Cantina but as you
would imagine they're gonna open a
little earlier what time are you opening
up JC 6 a.m. 6 a.m. 6 a.m. 6 a.m. on
Saturday holy [ __ ] have fun you
alcoholics and so Wow
I unfortunately won't be here I'll be on
the East Coast doing a signing at Jay
and Silent Bob's secret stash back of
Jersey yes I've heard of it too but yeah
so man if you're out here this is the
place to be although JC said last year
how long what time what was the line or
whatever the [ __ ] we it was a Friday
last year we opened at 2:00 p.m. and we
had 70 people in line on a Friday at
2:00 p.m. so you know how many people
were waiting in line about 250 to come
in for [ __ ] Game of Thrones yeah I
think Friday and Saturday we
about 250 in in line each night it was a
two-hour way just to get in you just
always a game of Thrones because it's
our Wars man like oh my god the money's
in [ __ ] the whites and [ __ ] like that
WI gah why is it because you're
committed to the cause yeah I mean we
said April 30th that's today we're
sticking to it we're gonna do more may
the fourth thing and then hopefully
people keep coming or else I'm gonna
have a sad May yeah we're talking about
I'm throwing some ideas around for the
fall and I just say that because I know
if you do it if you do it every other
month you just six times a year it's a
better chance of me being one of those
times like two movies yes it's a
convenience store it's quick stop and
get drunk with Dante so anyway what is
the what what can we expect the Star
Wars fan on may the 4th at this place do
you do anything different we we have a
special menu we're gonna blue milk green
milk life-debt drink it's a trap
drink and qui gon jin and juice and then
we're gonna we're gonna do custom
t-shirt puttin patio so we'll have like
three or four t-shirt designs that you
can actually like we'll have a wanted
poster scum and villainy most-wanted and
you will be able to text a photo of
yourself to the t-shirt printer and six
minutes later have a wanted poster with
your face on your t-shirt that you can
wear
throughout the day so we'll have like
yeah so we'll have like three or four
designs and then if you're just like I
don't want to be on your wanted poster I
have this sick Boba Fett costume and
then I've been photoshop myself on
Tatooine crawling out of the Sarlacc we
can print that for you too so it'll be a
totally custom t-shirt shop on
metaphoric and glorious age of wonder
that we live in it man how amazing but I
guess I mean you used to have to go to
the mall for that kind of technology and
[ __ ] now you better [ __ ] you're
getting drunk at the same time you're
like oh I'll get a t-shirt as well and
[ __ ] it off you go I'm gonna make a
t-shirt on my ass hold on text where
dick pick shirts are you gonna be
printing that Star Wars day look at my
lightsaber may the Schwartz be with you
and then we're gonna do at 11:00 I'm
gonna host Star Wars trivia from
probably 11:00 dough noon or 1:00 can
they win [ __ ] yeah so it'll be a $5 per
person buy-in and then whoever wins gets
the whole par so if a hundred people
show up at $5 a person you win 500 bucks
from knowing stuff that your mom told
you when is that ever going to come in
handy give it up for JC man that's my
life man still swinging that flag - I
was right - like Star Wars
look at this I'm right yeah man [ __ ]
that sounds still a [ __ ] I could win
that store was trivia although are you
picking the questions yeah I wrote all
the questions but it'll be fun like we
saw he actually goes deeper than I do
we've got I'm trying to last year I did
like movie by movie so it was like
what's the unit identification number on
the trash compactor or what's Princess
Leia cell number on the Death Star this
year yeah and you threw those out like
dumb sample questions
I'm like stopped I'm like oh my god is
that the level we're dealing with well I
hate this year's the tk-421 I'm [ __ ]
this is one of them tk-421
no that's the Stormtrooper that loop you
lost for us man don't buzz in on
Jeopardy we're gonna do a little
different I'm gonna do like finish this
line you know so like if you strike me
down finish the line I will be more come
more powerful than you can possibly
either and I got sound effects that
weren't like not mixed into the movie
like the raw sound effects so I'm gonna
play like a TIE fighter and you'll have
to say TIE fighter instead of like
spaceship or Millennium Falcon's like
identify what the actual sound effect is
which is harder than you think
when it's not mixed behind music and
everything else so that'll be an audio
and a full audio around so we've doing
some more genre based questions [ __ ]
love it dude you're living your best
goddamn life in this bar man give it up
for JC that's good [ __ ] can I get an
iced tea or some such [ __ ] I hate to put
you back to work I'm like can I get a
drink give it up for him can I get a
[ __ ] drink all right man a big
[ __ ] weekend in our world and in it
and not even that's the beautiful thing
used to be you had said there's a big
weekend in our world our world is now
the [ __ ] world the [ __ ] that like
we've liked our whole lives everybody
[ __ ] like so it's no longer like oh
man like did you see this thing like no
what is it we thank you we got to
identify some [ __ ] like the same [ __ ]
that we like everybody's [ __ ] mother
likes so we all saw the same [ __ ] it's
no more inside both of the two big
events of this weekend avengers endgame
of Game of Thrones belonged to everybody
but they smell like [ __ ] that belongs
specifically excuse me yeah really
[ __ ] I left on your lab they smell
like [ __ ] that specifically
comes from our world and [ __ ] that we
talk about here on a regular basis but
it's no longer inside baseball it's so
[ __ ] outside it's everybody's at this
point the culture it's no longer even
pop culture not when a movie opens at
1.3 billion dollars in three days
unbelievable three days first one in
history first one in history to open
over a billion dollars goddamn it
it took it took Captain Marvel 51 days
to make one point 1 million dollars an
endgame did it in three [ __ ] days and
you don't get that unless everybody in
the world goes yeah you know like I have
to tell my mom what to expect okay mom I
know you saw Black Panther it's cool
here's what happens post Black Panther
all right do I need to know you need to
know all of it for any of this to make
any sense like 45 minutes on the phone
my mom giving her the cliffnotes of 22
movies worth of Marvel she's like okay I
get it no you don't I don't anyway my
mom did not she was like you'll tell me
all about it tiger
I was like I totally will mom if I
brought her to that movie she'd sleep
through most of it like three hours and
[ __ ] she'd be like all is lovely
I took her to see a star is born because
she took me to see the original one when
I was a kid Barbra Streisand so I took
her to see the one with Lady gaga she's
all Twitter like oh my god I took you to
see this Mary kid I was like I know my
symmetry
closing a loop and [ __ ] we get into the
movie [ __ ] 20 minutes in and it's a
[ __ ] good movie you've seen I had we
talked about it she's a [ __ ] dope
movie and [ __ ] like he's a really good
director and so you're watching the
flick and I'm starting to get
emotionally engaged and I turned to my
mom because she's also a [ __ ] crier
and she had to be like right and she's
was out [ __ ] cold and [ __ ] in the
shallows now mom yes she didn't care she
was in the [ __ ] slumbers is where my
mom was so yeah she wouldn't manage very
well at the three-hour hand game and
stuff but not because she doesn't like
the genre and she loves that I love it
she's like oh Tiger how nice at age 52
still like things that you liked when
you were a kid and I'm like first off
mom I'm 48
you know I came out of you you might
remember you know but yeah it's it's a
lot of people's Mother's
[ __ ] wound up going this week and
you're right you don't get to 1.2
billion or 1.3 billion on just the backs
of the normal people that go yes they
all went and as shouted out from before
twice yeah you know how many people show
of hands how many people have seen it
more than once
actually MP to that's a I mean it's very
good but it's also a fairly conservative
like to get to that 11.2 number yeah I
wonder who else is going like cuz people
obviously who don't normally go to the
movies are coming out who is that I
think it's also people who don't
normally go to the movies and definitely
don't don't really go to movies twice
have gone twice and some three times and
some four times and a couple of five
timers I'm three I went to my third
showing today you saw three times yeah
I've seen it twice I went to the
premiere humblebrag
and then I and then I paid to see it
like a [ __ ] regular human being at
the movie theater up at City Walk at
8:00 8:00 in the morning with me and
Nate went [ __ ] hate 30 in the morning
holy [ __ ] man and you normally you know
that's one of the reasons I moved to Los
Angeles in the first place because I was
like you go to the movies at 8:00 in the
morning if you want and I never do that
but but here finally I've been living
here 17 years here was an opportunity to
[ __ ] finally do that thing and we
went up city walk I gotta tell you there
were more people there at 8:00 in the
morning was a Saturday or Sunday
Saturday more people there at 8:00 in
the morning than you would have expected
like that's why the 1.3 doesn't surprise
me cuz that theater is fairly packed for
like 8:00 in the morning yeah I went
today at 11 a.m. - almost sold out and
this is like a work it's a Tuesday a
Tuesday I mean I'm a degenerate but you
people should have jobs yeah
good on you cuz I'm here - what is all
right so you saw three times so three
times what insight do you have on the
third round that might be I didn't have
on the first two well I mean the first
time you see it at least the first time
I saw it I was just amazed
that it exists at all because there's so
much [ __ ] heavy lifting in that movie
there's so many emotional stories to
carry through there's so much plot [ __ ]
you gotta resolve you at some point
we'll have a giant fight with like five
thousand figures on the screen at once
conservatively speaking and you know
half of their names for any of that [ __ ]
to be like actually functioning is drama
is impossible like just just the fact
that they did it and got it done and
landed all those planes at once a second
time I saw it it became like oh here all
of the awesome moments they even those
little moments that I missed before you
know and I had watched Winter Soldier
before I saw the second time and so like
all of those little grace notes from
that movie the first Russo brothers
movie gets paid off in this one it's
like the on your left like you know I
tear up every time you get to on your
left right because that's the very first
line in the Russo brothers movie and it
just lands with such an emotional wallop
if beautiful bring that in there the
third time I saw it I figured out what
the movie was about because every other
time I was just like spoilers yeah he's
worthy I was huge [ __ ] moment I would
again I'm and humble brag but this is
inherent to the story I when I saw the
movie at the premiere I saw it with all
the Avengers in attendance and stuff and
it was mostly from what I could figure
out mostly cast and crew like because
they didn't have a cast and crew
screening or any of that [ __ ] like so
many people were seeing the movie
literally for the first time that night
so it was generally a bunch of people
like at the end cuz everybody got up on
stage and [ __ ] like that they then they
did a poll from the audience like how
many people are here with you know
somebody who made or worked on the movie
and it was 75 80 percent of the audience
so you were watching the movie with
people responsible for the [ __ ] movie
so everyone else 80% of that room knows
that eventually Captain America is gonna
lift Bollinger and still when that
moment [ __ ] happened
was thunderous like as if they didn't
[ __ ] know like I went again it sounds
like a humble brag but [ __ ] is part of
the story I got to go
chris hemsworth gave me a [ __ ] ticket
so I was there as his guest you'd
imagine he [ __ ] knew you know what
I'm saying
he was there when they I saw him in the
scene he was like I knew it and [ __ ] and
when it happened even he was a guy can't
help but be [ __ ] swept up ten years
of watching those movies and they
[ __ ] paid off even the slightest
[ __ ] interest in something like that
so yeah that that was a religious
[ __ ] moment yeah you know and and the
towards the movie about the movie the
movie at the end of the day is about
it's about mothers and sons and fathers
and daughters and generational being
able to say goodbye it's about taking
being able to get the second chance to
say the things you didn't get the same
before it's about Tony getting to talk
to his dad it's an authority that's my
favorite scene in the movie is Tony and
his dad I mean look I loved the whole
movie I'm not elevating this one scene
just I like the rest his dog [ __ ] it's
all great but I saw twice and my second
viewing I was able to be like alright I
know hands down with my favorite scene
in the movie is and it's between him and
Tony and his dad I think it's so
incredibly artfully done and so true to
Tony Stark's character like it would
have been tempting to go out mawkish Lee
to have him be like I love you you know
because we've seen his daddy issues
through a lot of these movies and
whatnot and here is the moment where he
gets to not through a computer
generation but literally in person
interact with his [ __ ] father
for me that was that was everything like
they landed that scene so incredibly
well by not letting Tony go weepy or be
like you know what I was [ __ ] wrong or
anything like that like they let him hog
and [ __ ] and he plays it off like you
know thank you for your service
but like the the fact that he just that
they let it get down to as simple as
Howard being like my old man there was
no problem he couldn't solve with a belt
without dollar son and then Tony saying
I you know I used to think my old man
was hard on me but now I
you know he was trying to do his best
that that like that's cathartic is [ __ ]
when you think about that character
because that character is one of the
most self-involved heroes that have ever
been presented in major media like in
fact the 10-year arc of him getting to
this is about like even even seated in
there by having Howard say like you know
let's just say personal self interests
have always had way the Queenan
outweighed the greater good and that's
he's his father's son so all these
movies is essentially his struggle to
become a [ __ ] hero and he spoilers
[ __ ] dies a hero dies finally going
like that's what he this is what it
takes he finally puts everybody else's
interests in front of his and he had way
more to lose in this movie than he had
when we previously knew him suddenly had
a kid so that scene with his dad is
everything when my second viewing I was
like Jesus the whole movie kind of rests
and pivots on it and I also loved the
scene with Thor and Frigga his mom and
now that you say what you said I'm like
oh [ __ ] no wonder I was so dialed in
because you may be right if that's what
it is
say again that's real smart it's about
being able to say the things you've
never gotten to say and the time travel
at the end of the day is letting these
characters do that then letting them
drop back into their old lives and say
what they've never been able to say with
the perspective they have now you know
it even ends with Tony being able to say
the things but via his recording to his
daughter and to his wife you can make me
cry don't be specific ago specific like
that
you know oh my god that cheeseburgers
moment with favreau haunts me man
[ __ ] haunts me like I want to find
him and give him a hug it was so
beautiful and as soon as she said
cheeseburgers even before he [ __ ]
reacted on-screen I was like that's what
Tony wanted when he got out of the
desert like Jesus you know but you know
and so it's a movie that is letting us
say goodbye to this version of the
Marvel Universe yes by having characters
getting to say their goodbyes to people
that they have meant everything to but
I've never said it too [ __ ] smart you
know and so to have you know even
[ __ ] Spidey to come back and just to
have Tony be able to hug him like I
brought the kid back like I did the
thing that I should have done I got to
embrace him because I never did every
time he wanted me to hug him I never
hugged him and now this one time I get
to do that and so that the weird marinus
of the last chapter in this particular
story being about last chapters really
resonated with me this past time it's
got to be intentional right there's
there's no leading to happen by accident
there's no movie that's not about
something you know you almost can't
accidentally spend that much money and
not have it say anything even if it's
the dumbest thing it's gonna say
something and so for them to decide that
listen we have this Daffy ass
time-travel thing which we're gonna poke
fun at the entire time it's magic the
Meg what did that say science is bad yo
yeah you know what both of those are
lessons you know and so like the third
time like some of the time travel
doesn't really work out like that right
it doesn't it's magic and magic has its
own [ __ ] rules and the rules are
whatever they need it to be like I'm not
I'm not smart enough to think like that
like I saw it twice and I didn't bump
into anything but the Internet way
smarter than me and I saw like something
on Twitter where somebody wrote like I
would like to be there when cap you know
cap has to return the stones at the end
hey look I'd like to be there when cap
has to put the ether back into Jane I
was like oh my god that's right how do
you do that ma'am can you bend over and
then somebody else pointed out but like
he's also got to return a stone to the
red skull what's that conversation like
like hey it's also like remember the
fort he's yeah but also in that scene
like it's a soul for a soul like if you
give him back the soul stone does he
have to give you back her soul well
that's what I'm wondering is that is
that the back door door like you know
because they're still talking about
there's gonna be a Black Widow movie and
after I saw this I was like how but if
you and I saw I was like maybe they
could do a previous story but like do
you really and we talked about it me and
Mark got we're lucky enough to sit down
with on Sunday remember here in an
episode of the bar Markus and McFeely
the screenwriters of infinity work we're
here chit-chatting they came over to my
house on Sunday and we sat down and
talked to them for to talk to him we
suck their dicks for two two-and-a-half
glorious [ __ ] hours and like talk
[ __ ] about the movie from one end to
the other and stuff and [ __ ] why did I
dive into that because we were just
saying it's a period Black Widow Black
Widow yes oh I brought it up in the
podcast if they did a story is because
you brought it up Mark said he's got a
theory that spider-man far from home
takes place before the snap yeah like
that when you see those kids in the
trailer in far from home
that is they are coming back from the
airport from being in Europe and then
they're on the bridge driving back into
into into the city when all this [ __ ]
appears in the air so that's how you get
all those kids who clearly like some of
them have been snap some of them not
whatever like this is all kind of before
then it could be [ __ ] I might be
making it up that's I am definitely
making it up but it could track if you
wanted it if they wanted to do that like
that there's there's a loophole for you
to have it and my question was would
would that be satisfying for an audience
like once you've seen endgame and not
that like hey man everything's got to be
as good as endgame but endgame puts like
sets the table to be like this is where
we are now in the Marvel Universe I
understand like you could always do
flashbacks and [ __ ] but if somebody was
like hey this whole [ __ ] movie takes
place before endgame like isn't it feel
weird at that point like wait no let's
move forward why are you going back
that's all Captain Marvel is like here's
an entire movie that takes place before
the events of this other movie good
point yeah but it's not sequel it would
be weird to see a sequel that was kind
of set in the past and it looks like in
the trailer that he's leaving the spy
this is what I take from he leaves a
spider-man suit behind because he's
bummed that Tony Stark's not alive
anymore that's what I now put through
the [ __ ] prism of having watched
endgame like oh maybe he's kind of mopey
and not into the hero bids because he
lost his buddy
could be it was anyway back to what we
were saying just that you know that yes
maybe there's a world in which Natasha
isn't dead because you know he's got to
give the soulstone back you get a soul
in exchange for that it's a soul for a
soul as we've been told like four
different times so ooh all right so
you're Captain America mm-hmm and you're
pretty good dude but you're still
[ __ ] you know justice so you're
willing to punch people in the [ __ ]
mush and stuff but at the same time
you're you know what adult Ron call him
God's righteous man or something like
that God's righteous soldier is there a
world where he brings back the soul
stone and it's a life for a life or
stolen for a life or whatever [ __ ] and
like the Red Skull could possibly be
released
mmm in exchange for the stone I don't
know if he does that he's not that good
a guy I could not if you could also get
it not if it's like you can have a
Natasha or that potato head [ __ ]
how about like my best riding buddy or
like the villain right might have
learned some [ __ ] at the edge of
eternity but still that's good
justification I don't want to be like a
member of the faithful in a world where
your God you're like look he may have
learned some [ __ ] at the end but [ __ ] up
too late
redemption is [ __ ] but yeah and so
like all the [ __ ] time travel [ __ ]
like I don't know how old cap is
supposed to be by the time you meet him
on the park bench but it feels like he's
more than a hundred years old and looks
kind of spry and so Super Soldier Serum
I guess but whatever who gives a [ __ ]
because the emotion of it lands so hard
right like by the time you're riding
with this movie by the time you're like
how does nebulous brain have time-travel
in it like why is she getting signals
from future self into past self I don't
care right I just don't care like could
you pick it apart probably like does it
make it like better to do so not really
somebody asked online or a bunch of
people were talking about wait a second
like [ __ ] and Peter Parker sees Ned in
school and they're both the same age
nobody's older like Scott Lang's kid
like who aged five years but what I
understood was a bunch of kids got bunch
of people got snapped so Ned and Peter
Parker were two of them maybe like now
I'm not saying everyone in that school
was snapped but like a bunch of them
probably did get snap so it be curious
to see like but we've seen the trailer
so we've seen like all his gang so what
they all got [ __ ] snapped
what a bad classroom day that was not
I'm saying like your homeroom and you're
like Peter's gone and Betty and [ __ ]
Jesus where's Ned yeah hey Ron is
ay-ay-ron here that's now Baraka Baraka
is here we're flash is flash dee-nice
you know the one thing that Cassie Lang
shut up sit down the other thing that I
thought I was on the fence about and
it's it's a judgment call and the boys
had perfectly good reasons why they made
this call the boys being Marcus and
mcmarson ofili I in my heart of hearts
wanted Hawkeye to [ __ ] die I and I
didn't quite understand the logic for
not doing that because who gives a [ __ ]
about Hawkeye well but then that's his
wife and kids but that's but that's
that's why you don't kill Hawkeye
because you just said it like who gives
a [ __ ] about Hawkeye so you give a [ __ ]
about black widow so if she's the one
that goes over it rips everyone's
[ __ ] heart out when they apparently
have a plan to bring her back so don't
feel too bad because if they killed
Hawkeye believe me he wasn't coming back
I know they're like we're gonna make a
show I'll believe it when I [ __ ] see
it you know but I personally would have
rather have seen Natasha register the
loss of Hawkeye and have to go to that
house and explain what happened like
just no [ __ ] make a great movie
better mark with your fanfiction but
yeah that would be [ __ ] cool you're
right that's there's more yeah because
nobody had to there was a certain like
point in the movie where you know NAT
dies not Black Widow sacrifices herself
and they show her from above and
bleeding and he's [ __ ] no and [ __ ]
and there's a swell of the music and
it's and they come back and there's a
moment of like where's NAT and she
didn't make it in the Hulk's mad and he
whips a bench at one point [ __ ] but then
and that's the bench caps it's on at the
end of the movie he threw it into the
futures amazing
that's a good fanservice right but they
did go kind of quiet on Black Widow for
a minute til Hulk was like I tried to
bring her back with the snap and [ __ ]
like that
but Tony's death was felt like like in
1983 is how [ __ ] like it all
encompassing it was like it was and you
know we love Black Widow but still
tony's was there's a lot more time and
it was in the right section of the movie
like black widow dies oh that's sad but
we got to go kill thanos [ __ ] you know
whereas Tony dies and Thanos is dead so
you're like oh it's so [ __ ] sad we're
getting to the credits yet you know
everybody gotta get their blacks on we
got to do a funeral of now with that
funeral too we should point out like
everybody's standing on and they do that
shot tracking like look at all these
[ __ ] look how expensive this is look
at all these movie stars first time I
saw it you know this is a movie that
like one of the main characters is not
real he's a big giant [ __ ] cartoon
and [ __ ] he's so convincing
you think he's there but he ain't really
there so in that world you know there's
a world where you stitch together that
funeral shot because you're looking at
that shot and you're like there's no way
on earth you could [ __ ] collect all
these people for one day in the same
[ __ ] place look at all these [ __ ]
expensive ass people man like I don't
care who's footing the bill like it's
just this is impossible
twenty million dollars shot before you
shoot any film exactly before you get to
spend anything out so in my mind and I
didn't give a [ __ ] I thought was
artfully done but I was like that has to
be [ __ ] stitched together but Markus
and McFeely told us on the show yeah
they're like we were there that day in
Atlanta like and everybody was [ __ ]
they're not crazy yeah they said they
built the one good bomb would have taken
out the entire Marvel Universe
but where would we be then like it's
irresponsible to put that many
characters in one place like the
fighting Fitzgerald you put them on
different boats and [ __ ] like who's the
Secretary of Education back in the
bunker yes don't they do that with the
government and that's the government
these are Marvel characters save them at
all costs yeah but that's impressive
that shows you the power of those but
could you imagine 10 years ago when they
started this they asked all those famous
people like do you do you think you
could all come out and do a shot for us
and be like go [ __ ] yourselves
10 years later though [ __ ] like you
know the the only one who nobody would
say no you know what I'm saying I mean
I'm sure if they called the DC
characters but hey lend his Batman they
would really go ahead yeah go go that'll
be good for the brand get over there man
hang out Tony Stark and then there was
that [ __ ] kid in the back of that
shot I was like all right first time I
saw the movie you know they show
everybody at the funerals like these are
the most famous [ __ ] people in the
world and then there was one person
where I was like wait who's that and
then I saw somebody else and I forgot
about it and then I was like you know
what it's probably [ __ ] Peter Parker
but I was like no Peter Parker was on
the dock with that man [ __ ] and I was
like you know what don't matter oh my
god there's Nick Fury you know and I was
on to something else and [ __ ] second
time I went back when it happened I was
ready for it [ __ ] because I was here
there crawling through the funeral and
[ __ ] and what I assumed was a digitally
stitched shot but we now know wasn't and
as they came to that kid
I turn to Nate and I was like what the
[ __ ] is that kid and Nate who knows
everything was like I don't know I was
like there's no one reason you're here
man [ __ ] so neither of us [ __ ] knew
and I got home and I forget who was will
Wilkins I was texting with him cuz he
loved the [ __ ] movie will does all
our digital stuff it's Marco and he also
doesn't show called bad heads he was
texting me about the [ __ ] movie and
he he was the one like him I put up a
one-hour review on YouTube and stuff and
so he was like hey I saw on a review
that you loved the Jarvis thing and I
said yeah I thought that was [ __ ]
amazing and he's like
Jarvis that guy who played Jarvis and
Jarvis was a character on the show
agent Carter he's like I guess you never
watched that I was like no I never did
he's like that Jarvis came from there
that he was a main character like he was
in a lot of adventures because I love
that [ __ ] moment in the movie where
Howard was like come on Jarvis and I was
like holy [ __ ] like they in the movies
they'd never acknowledged you know where
Jarvis came from other than the AI that
Tony had built into his house and [ __ ]
but if you know comics and you go deep
with the comics Jarvis was there [ __ ]
Alfred in Avengers mansion and [ __ ]
growing up in the comics so to see that
moment where there was a real Jarvis
like I was like oh that cracked my world
in two I wanted to like find the Russo
brothers and fellate them both to death
like that is amazing fanservice man that
you thought to [ __ ] include Jarvis
like that [ __ ] and then and [ __ ] will
was like no man Jarvis was in agent
Carter he's like so you're right it was
amazing fanservice but not for the
reason you thought big it was the reason
that they had done that on a show and no
Marvel movie had ever acknowledged any
Marvel show before and he's like that
was literally the first time that they
acknowledged anything that they'd done
on TV so it was a huge like fanservice
moment in a different way than I was
aware so he was we were talking about
that and then I was like this
[ __ ] in the know so I was like
hey who was that [ __ ] boy at the
funeral who wasn't famous and he goes
that's the boy from Iron Man 3 and I
said get the [ __ ] out of here I said
what an incredible fan service man that
dude was so important to Tony Stark that
whole [ __ ] movie he was the kid the
kid that got you over the haa the
problem is the kid is now like 10 years
older yeah and unrecognizable if you
watched Iron Man 3 he should have wore a
[ __ ] placard that said kid from Iron
Man Chris yeah I'm with you on that cuz
it really was like and I wonder if they
gave a [ __ ] or if they discussed it or
if they're like adds an easter egg cuz
it was a moment that I bumped into twice
in a moment where you're lost
like just emotionally you know like he's
dead and they're all sad - what the [ __ ]
is gonna happen
who is that Oh
I just [ __ ] took you out for a second
I think in future editions they should
Chiron just kid from but I thought that
was an incredible fanservice to include
that character as well I kept on
thinking sir nobody else who means
anything to [ __ ] Tony besides that
kid like the journalist he sleeps with
twice apparently Justin Hammer like a
Justin just show up in his [ __ ]
prison blues and like sorry Tony he
wouldn't be there though right cuz he'd
be like I hate Tony store but the
journalist is a good [ __ ] call but
how awkward would that be especially cuz
like well I remember pepper throws her
out she's like I do many things for mr.
stark including taking out the trash you
know and then she's at the funeral and
like how wait like 10 years ago didn't
you [ __ ] my husband you piece of [ __ ]
like this it's actually I do want to see
that movie now hi Morgan how are you i
[ __ ] your dad quite a bit yeah
Morgan's like who's that she's like oh
she's you know what she shouldn't be
here none of the rest him over here but
you're right like I thought about that
too when I heard it was the kid I was
like wait a second I did a mental
accounting of anybody he's ever
interacted with that wasn't an Avenger
or in other movies and [ __ ] and it's I
mean with the exception of like the
people who were dead like you know
[ __ ] Jeff Bridges who played what was
his name
oh oh oh nice dane such a metal name
there's he's dead but he they were close
but then you know so close that he was
like scar from [ __ ] Lion King and
then think that's where they got it and
then then and then Favreau directs Lion
King
there is something going on in Hollywood
isn't there there's also the lady doctor
from from Ultron she was only in one
movie so was that [ __ ] kid but the
kid like interacted with Tony she was
just like you know she's the lady who
built this yeah who built the body the
dot the doctor was like is she a card
machine yeah I mean if you need bodies
there I mean they didn't need buddies
but like I didn't bump into the fact she
wasn't there I was like where's that
doctor especially you don't want a
doctor there he'd be like where were you
we could have needed you when [ __ ] he
died you pieces she had get out of here
I was snapped [ __ ] I was
snapped there you go yeah
god you got an answer for everything
you're a good writer
[Laughter]
that's true
he's got you there you're not nearly as
good a writer as this guy is I'll tell
you man was amazing when we sat down
talked to Markus and McFeely we
literally like I hadn't I didn't I
wasn't aware of the news at that point
of what the movie had made so you know
when they sat down for us to record the
podcast it was like they were talking
about like what I was like boy it must
be a great weekend for you because I'm
just assuming it's doing well and [ __ ]
and they're like yeah yeah bless you and
I was like thanks for making the time to
come over and do this note at a certain
point they were joking there's like a
certain point you just can't keep
looking at the grosses or something like
that and I was like oh you guys must
know what the movie made already and
they looked at me as if I was just like
oh do you guys know there's a holiday
called Halloween you know and they were
like it yeah they've announced it 1.2
billion and I was like what the [ __ ] is
it can I borrow some money that right
there they're just two of the most
successful writers yes on the planet all
right that's nuts
man we got to tell them - I mean you
know mark knows him stuff but I got to
tell him I told him when we did the show
here but especially after endgame like
they're two of my favorite writers on
the planet because they're responsible
for so many [ __ ] movies I love the
boys did all the Captain America's yeah
like and I [ __ ] I've liked when we
were talking to him I don't know if it
was on the show before the show we were
talking about like how the movie ends so
beautifully on cap getting his last
dance with Peggy that he talks about in
Captain America the First Avenger in
ship so I was just like I knew the boys
had written Winter Soldier forward and
stuff but I was like did you guys write
the First Avenger as well and they were
like yeah that's ours and I was like
that's why you [ __ ] ended the movie
with like a Captain America First
Avenger reference cuz you wrote that
[ __ ] movie man I was like it's almost
like if I'd have known if I didn't know
better I would have thought you guys
also wrote Thor the dark world as well
because it's referenced so much in this
movie and they're like we did write Thor
the dark world we don't like to talk
about that so oh my god but it was so
brilliant because like they took the
movie that most people like yeah I think
I saw Thor the dark world like the
lesser child of the Marvel movies and
then made it reintegrate by playing it
so much in this movie it was almost like
they were like [ __ ] you you're gonna
like the dark world maybe you just
didn't understand it last time and god
damned if they didn't make me go back
and re-watch [ __ ] dark world I was
like this [ __ ] ain't bad now that I've
seen endgame you know it just took a few
years it's kind of brilliant
I wonder if Marvel ever released some
mega cut version of all those [ __ ]
movies with those scenes dropped back
into them chronologically speaking oh I
would sit down and watch it right like
you wouldn't even have to be like Oh
[ __ ] can you make yeah I make alcohol
Clockwork Orange that [ __ ]
all right so I feel like we've blown
this movie properly the is there
anything to talk about that we haven't
addressed about endgame do you want to
talk about me very eloquent on what you
said but I spent an hour talking about
it I don't know if there was anything
more you wanted to do I can get done
what you need an hour in about 10
minutes yeah yeah
take it I took it oh you're done I'm
done moving the [ __ ] out move and next
you want to talk about Thrones we should
talk about those we should also talk
about the fact that this year is unique
I think in all of pop culture history
and that we are bringing an end to this
wave of Marvel yeah is it done and the
fact that they signed off just like Star
Trek 6 made us both so [ __ ] happy yes
those who are like what the signatures
at the end of the credits of endgame or
it's like Chris Evans like the six
original Avengers each had their
signatures over their picture and their
names and the credits and the last Star
Trek movie that the original Enterprise
cast was in they did the same thing in
their credits so when I was watching the
movie and they did that I was like holy
[ __ ] man they just pulled the [ __ ]
Star Trek and we got to ask Markus and
McFeely like did you guys know that in
Star Trek they'd he's like that's where
we got it and it was a conscious
decision like the same way instead yes
they the same way that like like at the
end of that it was six yeah the end of
that Star Trek like that was it for Kirk
and a hora and [ __ ] all the normals
that bones and [ __ ] so they had him like
sign their names and the names went off
into the stars so the idea here was like
look we all know these cats are done man
like [ __ ] you might see this one here
there but we're done with these original
six Avengers as you know it so it was
kind of a double underline like to to
the hardcore geek like if you know your
geek history you know we're serious
Chris Evans is done you know cuz he
wrote his name and [ __ ] just like
[ __ ] Kirk did but this year the end
of the Avengers as we
and the end of Game of Thrones as we
know it yes prequels whatever and the
end of Star Wars as we know it will be
the end of this year the Skywalker's
taco will be over this is like one of
those movies words like every thousand
years the planets a lot wow that's crazy
there to be a year where you're closing
the books on so much big [ __ ] it's kind
of it's an interesting place to be
having loved this [ __ ] for as long as
I've been alive to find and knowing full
well that yeah there's gonna [ __ ]
they're gonna find a way to make another
Captain America thing it'll probably be
Sam you know you could also absolutely
do like 1960s like super retro spy
Captain America agent of shield I would
also watch the [ __ ] out of that you mean
with Chris Evans that's right yes that's
right well back in the past like Chris
Evans is ever like I [ __ ] need
another house he could pop back in and
[ __ ] do Captain America like in the
timestream and [ __ ] yeah you could you
could do like the James Bond era [ __ ]
classic spy shoe let me ask you that
question so Peggy Carter yes I remember
one of the movies she got married had a
husband had a life yes did she have kids
no I know we know she's got a need she
she had kids in the show right she does
have kids in the agent Carter show she
had kids um no the agent Carter shows
period and it's it's it's still when
she's back if she never met the dude or
whatever I don't think we see her meet
the so then Winter Soldier was the only
movie in which they referenced her life
without Steve and I knew she was married
but I didn't know if she had kids or not
apparently she does have kids now yes do
those kids exist anymore
there are way too many people answering
this question like I asked this guy who
apparently doesn't know also because
like it's way too many like Back to the
Future 2 answers even though this movie
goes painfully out of its way to say all
of that should it's nonsense because the
past you're president becomes the past
and your past becomes the future and
this is like the ending of [ __ ]
Trading Places to me man like it's just
too confusing I'm just like hey credits
we're good because again it's magic
whatever you want to have happen will
happen if they wonder to have kids
shouldn't have kids if they don't want
her they'll say time line [ __ ]
whatever fundamentally it doesn't matter
but wait so if if she does have kids in
some different time line that means
there's two Peggy's if according to the
so is the multiverse it's the multiverse
/ Back to the Future 2 of explanation
all right I mean I was okay with him
like [ __ ] zapping her husband out of
existence because I'm like a man like to
be fair if he didn't go on the ice like
they were probably gonna get together
and [ __ ] so that was all right with with
me but like kids that'd be weird but and
also like if you want to stick to the
Back to the Future at all he goes back
to the past and he is the husband that
Peggy is referring to when she's on her
own deathbed
she knew the whole time but she had
dementia so she was losing her mind and
so every now and again she Steve you
look so young
we had the writers in the room why
didn't we ask them that oh my god what a
great explanation
she made me baby he was the guy he could
have been the guy they could add kids so
but he didn't know so when he's sitting
there talking to her as an old lady and
[ __ ] and she's like my husband and [ __ ]
he had no idea it might have been him
yeah that would have been useful
information you know cuz I'm sure you
sitting there going your [ __ ] husband
what a dick and all she would have had
to say was it was you Steve you know and
then they could have showed us what
happened in them games you oh that's
good I like it I'll buy that [ __ ] that's
dope man God that made that's that's
making it better you know what you are a
better writer than that yes everything
ending man that's crazy so [ __ ]
although Star Wars not technically
ending although they did say they've
announced that like after the episode
nine we're taking a bit of a break right
and that this will be the end of the
Skywalker saga which has been the
driving force of Star Wars when it's
good ever since by high bar for them to
clear now that endgame has happened high
bar to clear but you which I every faith
that JJ will clear that bar but it's
like if I'm JJ I'm like [ __ ] after
endgame cuz you're like Jesus man like
[ __ ] and you can't hide behind the
excuse of like well they had ten years
to build that up it's like hey Star Wars
has been around a minute maybe don't
kill so many [ __ ] people
but yeah so Game of Thrones is also
coming to an end this episode was
immense and blurry and dark
yeah I mean look I understood like what
they were going for she had and I
understood like it worked beautifully in
terms of like hey it's dark or is
confusing yeah I know
I bought especially at night and they
say in the age of spotlights and Elena
you need a witch to light up some swords
and [ __ ] like that so it's dark and
that's scary man cuz we want to present
this as realistic as possible and [ __ ]
but the [ __ ] show's got dragons in it
so at that point realism really should
go out the [ __ ] door turn on a
goddamn light so we can see the [ __ ]
battle yeah you know and like they shot
for I think 57 days sorry 57 nights
and like you've done night shoots you
know what that [ __ ] like that just
destroys your mind I don't think I've
over the course of 25 years in
filmmaking I haven't done 20 that many
nights 57 nights I've never done 57
nights
total man and it was in the snow yeah
that shit's not CG yeah like so cold
apparently it couldn't snow because it
was too cold didn't anybody tell these
HBO people like effects and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] you could build that indoors and
nobody woman totally felt like now we
spent all that money on the Dragons yeah
that you can't see yeah and then we ran
out of money that's why one of the drags
got holes in his wings that was [ __ ]
up watching the Dragons fight it was
[ __ ] up because I wasn't sure which
dragon was which and who's on what back
it was a bit like watching a Michael Bay
transformers movie like I'm rooting for
somebody but I don't know which piece of
metal is which I see wings and I see
angry and I see somebody in a fur coat
on his back and I don't know what's
going on totally you know i the the bad
one was had snow all over him fair and
so like the the thing that I loved about
the episode was that yes it was like 75
80 minutes of just pure combat mmm but
that never felt like the same kind of
combat like every every like seven
minutes it became a different thing it
was like oh we're doing a siege that
we're doing horror out front with a
Dothraki with your flaming swords right
off into the night we never see what
happens to them besides the swords go
out yeah like super cool eerie and then
it's a siege movie and then it's like
they're just at the gates and weird like
throwing [ __ ] we're lighting fires we
got a moat we got a trench awesome and
then it's then it's a zombie movie and
then it's literally they're just teaming
over the wall
it becomes the senate's a Brad Pitt
zombie movie total fat zombies you know
and then it's this like super tiny
horror movie with its Aria in the
library and it's the Raptor scene in
Jurassic those are the scenes where it's
like we ran out of money run around the
hallways kid we got a room we got like
four guys in suits go you know and then
and then it becomes like just this
free-for-all just everything is gone
awry it becomes just as a disaster movie
by the end of it and so the fact that
they got you emotionally invested in the
turns of the battle scene because battle
can just get boring after a while I said
that in the after you know I'm sure like
most people I watched the you know after
[ __ ] Thrones where they talked to
Benioff and Weiss and they always
chitchat and they're always so serious
and [ __ ] like so [ __ ] deadly serious
nobody's ever gone like can you believe
all this [ __ ] out of [ __ ] dragons go
nuts you know but they're always just
like it's really important that Daenerys
has this moment and [ __ ] like that so I
I go into it I don't make fun of it I'm
like you're right Daenerys deserves this
you know yeah but in that he would they
were talking about like if we had just
done endless battle for 75 minutes you'd
get bored of that you know and I was
screaming at the screen no I wanted
there right like it helps to break it up
and do something for a minute and then
go back to it yeah I mean by the end of
the episode I realized two things that
Jon Snow still knows nothing and does
nothing yeah at the end of the day like
he could not have been there at all and
everything would have played out the way
it does yeah like he flew around a lot
you got to drag him that did what
dragons do which is blow fire on [ __ ]
he cut a bunch of could always control
those dragons
Aquaman style he kill the [ __ ] bunch
of zombies which stood back up again cuz
you knew they were gonna yeah and he'd
done that before it hard helm or heart
or whatever totally and he did not kill
a dragon the bad dragon the bad dragon
and you knew that one was bad news I was
like he's the the Indiana Jones of Game
of Thrones in that Indiana Jones in
Raiders of Lost Ark does not do anything
in no way does he actually hamper the
Nazis plan that's
if he's not there the Nazi still take
that [ __ ] Ark to that island and they
open it and they die so he's just kind
of Rosencrantz and Guildenstern and in
some holes am I gonna do anything
no why you're right cuz I it's just good
marketing man cuz the marketing was like
if adventure has a name it must be
Indiana Jones it should you like [ __ ]
yeah but now that I think about it it's
like if adventure has a name it must be
that Nazi because they're gonna go on a
journey and they're gonna get the
Argonne a governor we're really watching
the arc of their story yeah wow that's
weird twisted thanks dad for bringing me
the Nazi movie so yeah so John should
know I was disappointed in because I
want him to do more but then again his
story functionally is kind of over now
like his John snow has always been about
the white walkers from the jump
it's I went to Castle black um well it
was until they found out that John Snow
was also [ __ ] you know the guy who's
supposed to be sitting on the throne so
his story is just about to kick in
it could that's why I did it felt like
it was okay that's why I didn't feel
like he should have [ __ ] killed the
night king because you know the next
three episodes are all about who's gonna
wind up on the throne and presumably I'm
not saying it's gonna be him but he's
the one that's supposed to be on the
throne so his story is still going on
it's still going but he's not
emotionally engaged in that part of his
life well he may be now that the [ __ ]
white Walker good day like I look
forward to you know they kind of setup I
don't know I don't know the books at all
[ __ ] so I get to enjoy the TV show but
like it's past the books at this point
so you know they're setting up this
thing where he told you know Danny the
truth where he's like you're my aunt and
we [ __ ] you but uh which by the way he
didn't say you know I just want to point
out for the record and neither did she
there was no moment where they were like
what incest yeah should we ask you to
the [ __ ] throne it's like what do you
mean you want my job you know
so in but in that world where now that
they don't have to worry about the night
king and the [ __ ] whites and all that
[ __ ]
like now he might have to worry about
his life because there's a world where
she's like look the throne is mine
Schwab you know what I'm saying like
that's what I felt like they might try
to turn them against me they have to
pivot to give him story because again
he's been all about like the coming war
we all will have to band together or
we're going to die alone blah blah blah
blah I've got my fancy coat on I got a
dog let's go fight a war you know and
like I got a build all these armies I
got to stop the [ __ ] White Walkers I
stopped the White Walkers now what do I
do I guess I gotta fight on this throne
but I don't care really my you know not
watching that show I mean they got it's
three more episodes three more episodes
something's gotta happen but I unless
it's like it he sit around for three
episodes be like remember when we
[ __ ] killed the night King what's
that [ __ ] awesome cuz that's what I'd
be doing for the rest of my life like oh
my god he was gonna [ __ ] ruin like we
were surrounded by the dead and then
that little [ __ ] girl with no face
stab this [ __ ] right in a gun
came out of nowhere just what is awesome
how [ __ ] like tight was it though when
he grabbed her in the air and I was like
you pieces a shake if you're gonna
[ __ ] watch you're gonna make me watch
Arya Stark died when she was about to
[ __ ] you to death and then when she
dropped the thing I was a cook she did
that with Brianna Josh you're dead and
they [ __ ] oh it's so [ __ ] awesome
man so [ __ ] dope and no like they
didn't cut to him for an expression of
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die
just popped and they all [ __ ] drop
and the weird thing is I'm a writer
so I should have known that was coming
and like they literally you know [ __ ]
the witch is just like what do we say to
the god of death she's like not today
and when she goes like you know we've
met before she's like yeah and I told
you she and she's liking it and you said
I shut many eyes and she's like I told
you you'd close like [ __ ] of green eyes
and [ __ ] blue eyes brown eyes and
blue eyes and she's blue and right there
- kid looks at her and the kid it means
like a little not scared but like
[ __ ] like holy [ __ ] we are gonna die
like she looked
someone who's cool as cucumber finally
looked rattled
like Aria was like oh [ __ ] you are gonna
[ __ ] meet death and that moment where
she's like blue eyes that was her going
like I you know me and I know the future
and I'm [ __ ] telling you right now
that you kill someone with blue eyes who
is that and then she went and killed
[ __ ] Danny no and she went and killed
the pug in the night kick and she that
calm falls over when she [ __ ] walks
out of the room so [ __ ] metal because
she could you imagine if somebody told
you like it's you and you can believe
that person like you know people and I
feel like you could do it and then you
get killed you're like what the [ __ ]
were you know unfounded confidence but
like you're talking to a witch who
literally told you the future when you
were a kid and she was [ __ ] right and
that which turns around and she's like
you're gonna [ __ ] this in code she's
like you're gonna kill the night king
the first thing I would say is just say
it for real like don't [ __ ] make me
played a word game here and [ __ ] but
second off I'd be like yes and I would
go off and do the same [ __ ] thing but
watching him catch her I was like oh my
god they're gonna [ __ ] rip this from
us but man they delivered it was awesome
I don't think I've ever been quite so
happy to see a thing on a TV show like
this my face was his weird rictus grin
of joy I was so worried I was like how
do I turn at one point to my wife I was
like they painted themselves into a
corner like how do you get out of this
and she don't even watch the show and
even she looked at me like the little
girl and I was like oh yeah you know the
little girl we've been following for
like seven seasons knows herself from a
tiny little nothing in the middle of
Winterfell to a [ __ ] assassin ya know
that Mary Sue is gonna get it all done
this [ __ ] morons like do you watch
the show why somebody said that oh yeah
cuz you know the Internet the internet
is full of shitty people who like aa
reason Mary Sue she hasn't earned her
power
she's overpowered for who she is like
mother [ __ ] have you watched the guy
like ever they watch the same show that
we have watched no apparently not and
what they said Lyanna Mormont couldn't
kill the giant yeah I don't buy that I
mean like number one I'm going for that
argument period but number two it's like
we watched the whole [ __ ]
was about watching this little girl
become the person who has to kill the
night king like I don't think it didn't
come out of nowhere I wasn't like it's
not like they were like [ __ ] Samwell
Tarly killed the night king and [ __ ]
which to be fair he did kill the first
[ __ ] white Walker that we ever saw so
maybe in somewhere Samwell Tarly is like
[ __ ] you silent bill but you know it I
don't know I didn't bump into that one
iota but I didn't also bump into ray
being a [ __ ] Jedi or anything like
that either yeah I mean then again
that's an entire soccer built upon Luke
Skywalker suddenly being able to blow up
a [ __ ] dead star when he piloted one
ship one time back home yeah like he's
like the king of Mary Sue's if you're
gonna do that king of Mary Sue's as a
[ __ ] excellent name for a high school
punk rock band yeah man [ __ ] that was a
fantastic episode just like and and in
the same weekend as an end game which I
didn't think anything could be nearly as
entertaining his end game and [ __ ]
Game of Thrones did satisfy hell yeah I
don't know I mean thankfully nobody's
like which did you like better like I
just I like that's just like which do
you like better sex her head it's all
[ __ ] good they were they were both
stunning [ __ ] achievements in pop
culture in culture in general but
particularly for [ __ ] that like we've
liked our whole [ __ ] lives and
they're both like the accumulated story
that we have with those stories neither
of those two piece of entertainment work
unless you've been riding with those
stories for years yeah like you don't
come to like [ __ ] you know the long
night and be like oh I've heard this
game of thrones show is interesting tell
me what's happening here sir like none
of it [ __ ] means anything right
unless you saw a brand push out a
[ __ ] window and the things we do for
love and you're like oh I gotta see
where this goes yeah you know endgame
doesn't mean anything unless you know
the first time that Tony Stark says I am
Iron Man
like none of that [ __ ] plays unless you
have been with it for as long as you've
been with it unless it's earned our love
and paid that love back in dividends
very true and so yeah
thank you I I think that that like the
long night is a good episode with an
amazing [ __ ] ending but that ending
only works because I know the rest of
the story do you think that's true of
end game does endgame work as a movie
without knowing any of the other Marvel
movies like if you want it cold if
endgame was your first movie could you
enjoy it I don't think so if you haven't
seen I mean I thought fairly she
wouldn't have to seem infinity war
because you haven't seen that you don't
know why everybody is [ __ ] sad
right what this is so [ __ ] these
people are such bummers why it's just a
Tuesday guys I thought they had
superpowers by little pissy but ya know
that's wait so the Internet's mad about
Arya Stark [ __ ] killing the night
King which I've not bumped into how
weird is the internet [ __ ] mad that a
chance the answer to that is like this
is well done Nate is the Internet mad
that a rat is the true hero of endgame
that that random rat that walks across
the van in the San Francisco Locker like
if that doesn't happen none of this [ __ ]
I think that would be way more upset if
it was a lady rat oh you saucy says
satirical [ __ ] alright we've talked
about those let's do a little piece of
news and then we got to talk about some
sad stuff yeah a little piece of news is
happy stuff because it's not only just a
cool [ __ ] concept and again we live
in this age of [ __ ] magic and wonder
where you're seeing [ __ ] you never
imagined you'd see on the big screen
Suicide Squad to be directed by James
Gunn who as we've talked about before
was off of guardians 3 then got this job
doing Suicide Squad then Marvel said
please come back and he said I will but
I'm still gonna make Suicide Squad first
which is such a classy [ __ ] move
or a real big [ __ ] you move either way
right or a I like to get paid twice yeah
or like I'm gonna be the first director
to walk between two worlds or no he's
not cuz we didn't ya know what do you
mean judging joss whedon did a DC and
marvel that's right
or a quarter well he did a quarter DC
right like he didn't do all of it he did
he kind of came in on top of Zach he
hasn't done a standalone DC movie has he
but still he has whoo wow that's so
[ __ ] true man that's x-men and and
Superman are we allowed to say Bryan
Singer anymore let's just leave that
over there yes but good point as that
has somebody who's walked between two
worlds men but it sounds like Zach not
Zach James James is gonna be the first
one to walk between the modern marvel
world we're after we're doing that thing
that variety does like this is the best
opening on a Tuesday in 1983 like very
specific to walk between the Marvel
Cinematic Universe world and the DC
Cinematic Universe world and do to
complete films himself and not just
become in also even more to then go back
like I think that's yes straight starter
Marvel go DC then back to Marvel usually
it said like sort of persona non grata
once you abandon ship but he's produced
bright burn I think one of his relatives
yeah have his name on script I saw name
other than his name that's a gun on the
project but that movie looks amazing
bright burn Jesus man like the reverse
Superman dark Superman what if Superman
was naughty all right so we talked about
that just so we can brag a humble brag
about a friend of ours Dave dismal chin
the lovely individual who's been on our
show and also you know I'm from like a
zillion [ __ ] movies and [ __ ] and he's
in a zillion more movies in dune this
year he's in he's in Jay and Silent Bob
reboot but he's all
just got this huge gig in Suicide Squad
yes playing [ __ ] of all characters
one that I never imagined we'd ever
[ __ ] see like in on the big screen
polka dot man the deep cuts [ __ ] DC
Batman villain one of the spookiest and
stupidest and [ __ ] but like that just
hearing that they've got polka dot man
in the movie made me
triply excited for the James Gunn vision
of The Suicide Squad
I enjoyed the suit first one David Aires
version but James is like just a [ __ ]
genius savant when it comes to weirdness
like never mind the Guardians [ __ ] look
at his other look at slither and [ __ ]
like that look at his [ __ ] that got him
the Marvel jobs he's just real clever
and creepy and [ __ ] like that
so I look forward to his version of
squad I think it's gonna be so like was
that thing where you're like hey man I'm
[ __ ] undercutting the mainstream
cursive thank you you beat me there who
needs a [ __ ] app yes I think it's
gonna be more subversive than the first
I think it's gonna be a superhero movie
and stuff but I think it's gonna have a
subversive street running through it and
I guess that's kind of what guardians
has running to it but I think he's gonna
be able to up the ante with Suicide
Squad because guardians pg-13 movie and
suicides go up probably gonna be an
honor right could be first one was ya
can't imagine that he's like I'm signing
up for the pg-13 version of this I mean
then again Warner Brothers might say
we'll make it a pg-13 version of this oh
and that might be the mandate it could
be but I also think that there's a
chance to make it a more balanced movie
without Will Smith because Will Smith
always threw off the dynamics of that
team explain because Will Smith demands
things that a movie star demands which
is screen time and it has to be about me
and I need a backstory and I in some
faction this movie needs to revolve
around me and my ego which to be fair
you Will Smith and I get it
but if you take that out of a scenario
you can have like a Dirty Dozen where
none of these [ __ ] are movie
stars
they're all just actors they're just
great actors and they all can serve the
story you needed to serve without you
know you're a movie star being like ya
know this is great but I want to have
want to have a daughter why do you need
a [ __ ] daughter you dead shot cuz
well that need to be fair floyd lawton
did have a kid yeah but it didn't need
to be about his kid
no but do you remember the miniseries
when in the comics years ago I remember
[ __ ] reading this be like this is one
of the things that resold me on comic
books I got out of comics when I went to
high school and [ __ ] and then Walter
Flanagan was the guy that got me back
into comics after high school and he was
like Deadshot was one of his favorite
characters is like read this [ __ ]
miniseries it's so [ __ ] up like his
kid gets killed and I was like what
that's how you sell this comic book and
[ __ ] and it was it was compelling his
[ __ ] he had a kid the kid got killed and
that's why it's not that's not what made
him a killer he was already a [ __ ]
killer that just happened in the process
of the story there was some real nice
touch to it so when they did a kid in
the in the movie first I was like oh my
god protect that child at all costs
because I know what's gonna happen but
they didn't go that route but you're
right that's true they probably wouldn't
have included that if it was just a
random person not Will Smith if it just
gets to be Task Force X and it just got
to be a bunch of guys doing bad [ __ ]
even though there were people cool
Will Smith is what gets you to suicide
squad right like do you think they make
that movie without Will Smith the first
time like he was the [ __ ] the green
light I would imagine he was the biggest
movie star in the [ __ ] thing and then
would have been something that made a
studio feel safe like alright this is an
untried property it does it's not Batman
or Superman or if I could Wonder Woman
but let's give it a shot if Will Smith's
in it will work out maybe although I
could also say and not that I really
want more Jared Leto Joker but it
actually could have been about Joker and
Harley Quinn if you don't have to
shoehorn in a bunch of [ __ ] Deadshot
story mm but that's not there because
movies not great but we get another one
anyway I saw him or did I see him like a
picture of him getting ready for Morbius
the vampire know what nca I think I saw
like some shot of him a beard or facial
hair and said I didn't know if they were
shooting that movie or not is that a
Marvel movie
it's Sony it's one of those like you
know it's a cider verse Marvel movie and
[ __ ] doesn't have Kevin Feige blessing
or touch yet I mean let me tell you
something after [ __ ] 10 years of
Marvel movies
that endgame movie Kevin Feige should
run for president who the [ __ ] wouldn't
vote for a man I mean I'm sure it'd be a
huge drop in pay and prestige but like
god damn it to make that [ __ ] work that
guy had a [ __ ] plan I'll take eight
years with that [ __ ] cat no heartbeat
man how sweet
when the boys came over the other night
one of them had heard that had watched
my review like which one was it it was
Stephen it was McFeely Stephen was
referencing it and then Chris was like
what are you talking about and he's like
Kevin reviewed the movie it's like an
hour long and he cries all throughout it
and he goes and Kevin watched it Nozick
you damn Skippy Kevin watch that Kevin
watches everything he does
Kevin's his own biggest bang and he goes
no not you Kevin Kevin Kevin Kevin Feige
watch it and I was like even though I
know for like I know Kevin I was like
give him Feige knows my name like oh so
so delighted he was like he watched I
was like did he say he's that he loved
it I was like oh my god can you hear it
shouldn't even be that surprising right
cuz like he's a geek just like us and
stuff he has similar interest in the
stuff that we have been interested in
but we were talking about his baby yes
and I guess he popped in to make sure
that we weren't like it's alright
whatever no [ __ ] yeah he got a love
letter off of that [ __ ] video for
sure man but all right now I'm onto
something that [ __ ] should run
for president and I'm not even saying
like [ __ ] Trump I'm just saying like I'd
vote for that guy in a [ __ ] heart
beat like hema gave us Marvel movies I
could count on him and
and if you just ran on a platform of
more Marvel movies oh my god I'm like
president-for-life
I want that man to be kept alive at all
[ __ ] costs until I [ __ ] pass away
then you can die but like [ __ ] as
long as he's alive in this world and
make him and as long as I'm alive in
this world I want him alive making
[ __ ] entertainment those movies make
me so unbelievably [ __ ] happy he is
one of my favorite creators on the
planet because I know like he didn't
direct it and right but he directed and
wrote the entire [ __ ] arc man he had
the vision he was the guy that believed
and [ __ ] like especially when it's easy
to [ __ ] go now like this movie open
to 1.3 billion but let me take you back
to [ __ ] an Iron Man when they
announced that their do an Iron Man the
whole world didn't get a huge [ __ ]
hard-on or get super wet and be like oh
my god they were just like Iron Man huh
which one is he
because Iron Man wasn't really like the
[ __ ] top tier a-list character in
Marvel Comics he was one of their
flagship and stuff but like even in
sales
nobody was [ __ ] with with an Iron Man
anymore and [ __ ] was a Wolverine [ __ ]
world by then so when they announced
Iron Man as a movie it wasn't like this
is gonna be amazing people like Oh
that'll be cute and then that summer
iron man comes out and it's an
incredibly special film this movie's
held up to every [ __ ] viewing I've
ever is a perfect film there's nothing
wrong with it it's Star Wars imaginative
and wonderful like true family
entertainment but [ __ ] could work if
you're not a kid as well excellent
[ __ ] film why did I bring that up I
got lost in my own story
Feige it must be foggy foggy people
wanted that excited thank you so when
Iron Man comes out they weren't like
[ __ ] the whole world wasn't like show
us your iron dick and [ __ ] they were
just like Oh Iron Man maybe it'll be
something Robert Downey jr. is he okay
like it wasn't it wasn't like a [ __ ]
like sure bet
so Dark Knight comes out like a few
months after iron man iron man comes out
and you're shocked at how [ __ ] good
it is you're like holy [ __ ] Iron Man's a
really good [ __ ] movie man good job
guys and then
two months later Dark Knight came out
and everyone forgot iron mags they're
like [ __ ] Joker is cool again you
know and suddenly [ __ ] that was it
they sucked all the air out of the room
and then quietly like they were like
look we made a bunch of money we know
we're doing the right thing good for the
Dark Knight and [ __ ] they've got their
thing we're doing something different
over here we're doing something a little
lighter we got an idea we think it could
work we got the Hulk next we got some
other things cooking and [ __ ] grew it
from that from a property that wasn't
guaranteed took it all the way all the
way to this 1.3 billion dollar opening
that's storytelling you know what I'm
saying and some people be like that's
business [ __ ]
that's a guy who loved these characters
as much as all of us did and said why
couldn't they have really great movies
about these characters these characters
been working 30 40 50 [ __ ] years like
this trying true when you look at
superheroes and costumes and movies this
isn't we talked about with Markus and
McFeely like you got to think back to
the x-men where they make jokes about
how they wouldn't wear the [ __ ]
costumes like what do you want us to
wear a blue brown spandex well yellow
spandex like because they were wearing
you know [ __ ] matrix black outfits
and [ __ ] so slowly that changed now your
heroes look like your heroes from the
comic books and [ __ ] Markus and McFeely
were going like that's Kevin that has
everything to do with Kevin they were
like Kevin's point was always like these
characters are tried and true this IP
has been around for a long time and
everybody knows what they look like why
the [ __ ] would you change what they look
like
makes no sense make it look like the
books that's what I love I love the look
of Thor so we got Thor that looked kind
of close to Tori
you know it's it's nuts that they
actually did it yeah there's an exchange
stuff for the recent Thor
which I would argue might be my favorite
Thor it was the first time I looked up
at the screen and looked at Thor and I
was like my god I look better than Thor
I like that he was schlubby man it gave
like gave us dadbod people somebody to
be like that's my hero I'm just like him
there's an exchange in Steve Jobs why
I'm talking about this we'll get there
where Steve Wozniak asked oh the movie
Steve Jobs Steve Jobs you know you're
not a programmer you're not a designer
why what do you do yeah and he says well
I once talked to the conductor of the
San Francisco you know Orchestra and I
asked him like you know what what is it
that you do you don't play anything I
said well like I play the orchestra the
orcish is my instrument like Kevin Feige
is the conductor of the multi-universe
he's not a writer he's not a director
but he plays he tells these stories
using that entire brain trust as his
instrument and like here's the story I
think we're gonna tell tell it I mean
you've got to play your first violin the
way you're gonna play your first violin
but I know the guy who play it the way
that'll harmonize with what's happening
with the dude over there and the timpani
and the dude over there on the [ __ ]
cello like I have it in my head how all
of this is going to sound when it's
great you just have to trust me and give
me all of your money King okay and after
what they've done I'll give him money
for the rest of my life I don't even
care if like one day the movie started
become really like [ __ ] bad or
something I'd be like you know what for
ten years of happy [ __ ] memories that
I can still enjoy today because I can
watch any one of those Marvel movies
from now until the day die they'll still
be entertaining I've been watching Iron
Man for ten [ __ ] years it's never
gotten bad I've never been like I could
skip this [ __ ] scene
I even like but to be fair take it with
a grain of salt I like Iron Man two very
much as well and most people like you're
alone there buddy
yeah it's a giant grain of salt to me it
was just more that you know it was the
closest thing to a quote-unquote sequel
that they've ever done you know Marvel
Universe all the movies kind of weren't
really sequels they moved the ball
forward and told new stories and [ __ ]
and spread the universe but Iron Man 2
really felt like like Rocky - it was
just like did you like the guy in the
metal suit here's [ __ ] more
you know they weren't necessarily like
like we're building a universe here they
were trying it yet but they were like
you know let's let's make this movie
right here but I even like that movie
all of this is to say congrats Dave to
small chin for getting cast huge gig for
Dave that's awesome
and that means we'll get inside info on
the movie bring them back so if you hear
an inside dope from us on Suicide Squad
you know where it came from
and the wave right now is desperately
signing an NDA yes you can't talk to
them now the last piece of news is the
sad piece of news yeah which is Monday
John Singleton's family took him off
life support after suffering what seemed
to have been a catastrophic stroke and
he died at 51 I mean all of that sucks
there's not piece of that intro that was
good
John Singleton was like us he was way
into this [ __ ] when I first met him like
all I wanted to do was talk about boys
in the hood because it was influential
for me and all he wanted to talk about
was comics because he's like I know you
like comic books he goes what about a
Luke Cage movie and I was like [ __ ] yes
are you gonna do that he's like I'm
trying I'm trying to do it like every
time I talked to him he was working on a
comic book themed project and [ __ ]
an incredibly talented man who made and
this is gonna sound weird because I'm
obviously not an african-american
filmmaker but like he opened doors for
people like me and that is to say
Outsiders you know what I'm saying I
know he uplifted the race and opened the
doors for other I didn't get first what
Academy award-nominated he was the first
african-american to be nominated for
Best Director or Best Screenplay
so history-making there but beyond that
community is also just he wasn't to the
manor born he's a film school kid and
his story if I remember correctly was
like you know some agent came to speak
at the school and he had us see where he
attended and you know he was like I got
a script like I don't I don't need
advice I got a project right here got
himself an agent
Robert Newman Robert Newman got a script
into Columbia I think and Columbia is
like we're gonna make this movie because
this is a raw hard-hitting look at a
world that like we pay people to try to
make pretend so this is beautiful we're
gonna take this in and made a
history-making film so to watch an
outsider become an Insider and then be
respected and get [ __ ] nominated for
the highest awards in our [ __ ]
business and [ __ ] that that's another
person that gives you permission that
makes you think it's possible you're
like okay he's he's not likely either so
if the unlikely can get in maybe I could
get into so I loved the boys in the hood
laserdisc I would listen to his
commentary track all the time and [ __ ]
like that because he also sounded like
me young and also like our cultural
references were the same and that's
important you see somebody go before you
know like hey they're kind of like me if
they did it maybe I could [ __ ] do it
too so I loved meeting him and [ __ ] and
and we didn't we weren't [ __ ] like
super friends or anything like that but
whenever we saw each other it was really
[ __ ] warm and wonderful and when I
heard he had the stroke I was like wow
he's incredibly young man I'm sure he'll
pull through
and then all of a sudden this news broke
and it was beyond heartbreaking 51 kids
is I say this is somebody who's 48
that's nothing like young and he wasn't
an unhealthy human being like it's not
like oh he [ __ ] love cheeseburgers
and [ __ ] cocaine all right as far as
I knew none of that like he was pretty
clean tin whistle guy so I don't you
know it's it's genetics of course plays
a big part and stuff it's just one of
those commercials for like go get
yourself checked out have midlife
because if a guy who looks as healthy as
John could be taken down I mean the same
thing didn't this is what happened to
Luke Perry right he had a stroke that
took put him into a coma and then didn't
recover yeah I mean my dad had a stroke
but he lived
I always thought strokes were
debilitating but I didn't know they were
lethal it depends I mean it's it's it's
a storm in your brain that just like
starts a short circuit [ __ ] and
depending on the size of the stroke you
can recover from it you can rehabilitate
some of those neural pathways and
you know the part of you that I got a
friend whose dad had a stroke and he
lost like most of the left side of his
body therapy and time and like you can
eventually gain some of that use back
but if it strikes you like a [ __ ]
lightning bolt then it's just like I
don't know what we can do the only thing
to do was to make him comfortable I
guess so they had to make it somebody
had to make a decision to pull him off
life support yeah
they right up they were like it's gonna
be really yeah man so [ __ ] sad and
and just like shocking and like you know
he was just here like that kind of thing
like Denny worked on snow fall yeah as
his shown on FX
didn't he also do yeah yeah yeah then
but also he did didn't he do episodes of
OJ people versus OJ or something like
that
yeah like he became because you know
making a movie is a difficult thing to
do like he in his career which spanned
about 25 years have made less than ten
of them so right yeah yeah because it's
it's [ __ ] hard to get a movie made
even if you your first movie out of the
gate is boys in the hood you know like
it's difficult to do even if you're
changing the face of the culture it's
difficult to do you know even if you
make a fashion the Furious movie which
he did it's difficult to do which one
too fast too furious he did the seat
that was the first sequel yeah Wow yeah
but like you know that wow the way film
the way black film especially had looked
when boys in the hood came out was you
never went to California like the way
black film was always who's New York
because Spike was this sort of like the
touchstone person right and the first
time you got a look into here's LA
here's what it feels like on the ground
from this perspective it's the first
time anybody had seen that yeah and I
saw some interview where he referred to
himself as the first black film brat
because he was like you know Spike came
before me and did all of the [ __ ]
like he burst all the doors open and
before him was Gordon Parks and before
him was was melvin van peebles like
there was there was a lineage of like
barrier breakers who did so much [ __ ]
hard work and by the time I got there
I got to make things that made me happy
you know that vac I could chase wings
when I wanted to but I want to do a
thing about this [ __ ] girl is a poet
I want to do the thing about three guys
who go to school at a black college for
the first time I want to do a fast and
furious movie like I could I could make
things that made me happy and I did not
have to worry about breaking down so
many of those barriers and then I could
pull other people up behind me because
it hadn't been as hard for me as it was
for them and so just that sense of he
understood his place in the business and
how he was the first of not many by the
first of some and the responsibility he
felt to help make more than just him
that boys in the hood movies real star
maker as well man think about it Kubo
Gooding jr. mm-hmm Ice Cube's first real
acting role Regina King right Morris
Chestnut like all people that are still
[ __ ] working
yeah totally and then Laurence Fishburne
Angela Bassett who ya know Laurence
Angela Bassett yeah man like while they
were working before Joe working before
but even so they never stopped yeah they
never stopped no it's it's oh my god
both of them wound up in Marvel movies
he was an ant-man in the wasp and she's
in black panther yeah it's a circle of
life oh look at you look like but but
yes gone gone too soon probably had lots
more stories to tell yeah it's just
weird like I've gone too far to see like
he was a mentor but he was definitely I
don't he's in my DNA that sounds sexy
but it's not it doesn't mean that it's
without him doing what he does I don't
know if I ever wind up doing what I do
but I do know that what I wound up doing
was informed by his journey and what he
did so he is in my creative DNA you know
it's like when I watch the Jay and
Silent Bob reboot I've been cutting it
and stuff and so as I watched the movie
I'm like where'd this [ __ ] come from
and [ __ ] and there are things I see
periodically where I'm like oh that's
bad news bears like this is in my DNA
it's just this is how I see the world
and [ __ ] he his movie and that ladies
just particularly and his story about
being an outsider who against all odds
[ __ ] made his mark told his [ __ ]
SOI sang his song it's in my DNA to this
day and so when I heard that he passed
it was pretty powerful considering like
we weren't thick as thieves I was like
oh my god no like I cuz I thought we
were very close an agent we were but it
hit me in a weird hard way man is it
lost a real big loss is there any more
details about it are there any more
details but it's that's all I'd heard
yeah [ __ ] he never got to make his
comic book movie that's the really sad
thing man like he was a true believer in
this [ __ ] long before it was profitable
were popular he was trying I mean like
he said that closest he got to making
his comic-book movie was shaft he's like
it's kind of same thing he's just like
he's just not wearing a mask so still
though he would have handled the Marvel
character really really well it's a
bummer man let's give it up for one of
the great ones man John Singleton
it uh it's it goes in a weird way life
ladies and gentlemen so in honor of John
for the next week figure out what you
want to do and do it John doesn't have
the chance to do that anymore so that's
that's what should come from all death
yes grief especially if we know the
people but it should always every death
should be a reminder that like you got
[ __ ] to do and you do not have all the
time in the world to do it so get
cracking kids that being said we're
jumping into the second part of the show
ladies and gentlemen and that is the cue
a part of the show man that's where we
turn to you the audience and find out
what you want to know man JC has a
microphone screen XD next not 40x
Oh beautiful so we got some swag to give
away and stuff as per usual Bret Deacon
gave us tickets but this time it's not
40 X it's green X what is screen X the
difference Chyna rapper oh it's where
the movie gets even wider and [ __ ] like
that
like you like wide movies well look at
this and it just keeps going and [ __ ]
much girth so we've got tickets thick
with 2 C's we've got so much [ __ ]
high so many tickets to give away thanks
to Brett Teague and they're good folks
the screen acts down by the same people
do 40 X yes correct right you're all so
thanks to those folks they always give
us tickets to give away to you the
question askers now anyone can ask a
question all we ask though is a whoever
asked question you have to ask something
that both me and Mark can answer so
don't just ask something like [ __ ]
what's J like in real life like ask him
yourself he's in the parking lot but
it's more about something we can both
discuss you do that and you're gonna win
some tickets to to screen X or what's
this I'm not sure this is for you
Westeros swag Game of Thrones swag right
on so we got some game
three shirts three shirts and five sets
of tests and a ring
ooh nice all right so you're gonna win a
ticket tickets and a shirt or tickets
and some some gak jewelry yeah you're
gonna get something for nothing and
that's the important part
JC it's his place we sent him around
with a microphone and he picks people
and and we got our first person what's
your name Celine Celine everyone give it
up for Celine first of all this is such
a pleasure thank you so much my question
would be if either of you were asked to
play a Marvel character in a future MCU
movie cameo or whatever which one would
you think you'd pull off the best do you
know something I don't cuz the way you
got me real excited the way he said it
if you're ever in a Marvel movie which
you maybe know it's a way tweeted again
was the question specifically if either
one of you were asked to play a Marvel
character in a future MCU movie yes it
could be a cameo it could be a CGI
character I could be anybody who would
you think you would be able to pull off
the best could it be somebody that is
already in a movie or does it have to be
somebody who's brandnew has to be
somebody bring it can't be someone like
krahgg or something like you absolutely
like a new character that hasn't been
introduced yet so this is your character
that you have to make your own MCU
MCU specifically if you want to go more
broader you can do that too if you want
like DC but specifically MCU I feel like
going forward I mean I don't know if
they're gonna be bringing you know I
want it like say ooh
MODOK but I know I you know what I had a
feeling I know I had a weird feeling you
would say that I'm not gonna pick it
because I don't want to steal it from
Patton Oswalt that's his [ __ ] dream
so so not MODOK but here nobody has a
character though in agents of shield
that's yeah are you kind of but there's
there's one coming I think I well the
daredevil Netflix show which is now
defunct they didn't agra recognize
the movies which means they could
conceivably do movie daredevil so if
they were doing movie daredevil then I
would like to be foggy Nelson is a rich
history Favreau played him once in a
movie he's a director and [ __ ] and then
his career blew up so maybe if I played
him I could direct a [ __ ] live-action
remake of the Great Mouse Detective or
something I get to make jokes he gets to
make billions anyway I would I would do
that I'm not gonna pick a here own [ __ ]
but I was leaning a foggy Nelson he'd be
in a good chunk of scenes and you
probably have to give the hero the pep
talk and [ __ ] like that plus you know a
secret so you get to play that and you
get to be funny and sure that's that's
all on my wheelhouse anything else would
they be like you got to work out I'm
like [ __ ] you so foggy Nelson you I'm
trying to Rack my brain for chubby black
dudes man they they make people young in
those movies Rob was like a giant rock
man you don't have to be in Baku Baku is
for me what fat Thor is to you a little
thick and still get it done I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go mojo ooh
[Music]
for [ __ ] long shot mojo yeah
what a great call yeah cuz I can be all
[ __ ] CG and yeah well good and-and-and
yeah it just seems like it'd be fun oh
can I change my answer I want to be
Lockheed oh the dragon yeah cuz they
don't even have to show up to work I'm
just doing a voice and [ __ ] like that so
here's a say anything and I'm like this
diesel I show up to every premiere and I
only said I am Groot once and all of
endgame and [ __ ] I mean yeah that counts
hey you know what counts that question
it was excellent
you [ __ ] win give it up for last
challenge
great job man give it up hi JC where are
we going next
Sam Wilson what's up then
how you doing them say your name Sam no
my name's Rashad
what is it Rashad Rashad everyone give
it up for Rashad and Wilson
it was a nice bookmark
what's your question for shot fire away
sure notes I know I wanted to write it
out because I was really nervous I first
want to thank you Kevin and Mark for
taking time out of your busy schedules
to regularly share your experiences as
both fans and pop culture and
professionals in the entertainment
industry I imagine a handful of us our
creators here in this lovely bar and
many more who watch and listen to these
wonderful podcast episodes but every
ounce of energy into our artwork which
fills us with the katuk the cathartic
joy with every new episode of that man
be on YouTube prove that a plan to make
a living beyond by doing something that
we love is neither impossible is neither
impossible nor impractical excuse me I
just want to say thank you again at the
bottom of my heart I really appreciate
everything you guys do just watching you
just gives me so much confidence and
with that like to ask you if it's
possible three questions you that
beautiful soliloquy you could ask me for
head and I'd be like all right my mom is
here so Mimi fair enough
mine too all right fair enough that's
lovely absolutely ask three away great
thank you the first two is what advice
would you give to an aspiring writer
director and producer who is attending
to break into the industry and may I
give you two my resume you're gonna have
a wait is that that's the first question
the first question yeah the first
question is what's your advice and two
is may give you my resumes and then
there's a third yes look at that
anticipation all right first one is
let's do the resume you can absolutely
give us your resume what was the first
question again that takes longer thought
the first question was what advice would
you give to an aspiring writer director
and producer who's attempting to break
into the industry okay that one is
always my standard advice which is the
only currency that you have in this life
as a creative entity is your voice or as
not just a creative entity as a human
being is your voice it's absolutely
[ __ ] yours it's your voice is your
currency that's the thing you get to
spend a lot of people come out here and
they try to shape it up and do what's
popular and like what are they doing
that successful I'll just do that best
chances of success aren't based on
mimicry it's based on you jumping into a
room and saying something nobody's ever
heard before I'm like holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] new let's try that let's do that
so even though conventional wisdom would
tell you to like do something
tried-and-true because if it's worked
before it could work again and stuff I
always kind of rather I'd rather die on
the cross of like you've never seen this
before like you know like it or not like
it's yoga hosers but like you know some
people about holy [ __ ] that's original
and some people be like goodbye again
you know and [ __ ] take off and [ __ ]
but at the end of the day I look at that
thing and I'm like I love it it's
exactly what I wanted it to be it's my
voice it reeks of me you know which
means like that works in both ways it's
great if it's all you and it's bad if
it's all you because if they don't like
you that I don't like anything of that
but that's all I got to give in this
world is me like that's the only thing
that's any value my opinion my point of
view my perspective my story so I say
tell your story at all costs don't worry
don't ever listen to somebody say like
that's not what people want nobody
[ __ ] knows but anybody [ __ ] wants
ever so there everything is an open
possibility so long as you're bringing
something to the table that nobody else
has ever heard before and that's your
voice that's what you've got the whole
life you've lived everything you've
[ __ ] done that's valuable and they
have not put it up on the screen
presumably unless you're like no my life
is exactly like endgame in
no probably not so you're gonna be able
to bring him something they had never
seen before that's the only reason I'm
standing in a [ __ ] bar talking to
people in Hollywood something that if
you had told me in my early 20s like one
day you're gonna be doing that I'll be
like do I blow dudes in the bathroom
like what is the why might a barge but
like the notion that like there is no
[ __ ] set future that every day
there's a different way to find an angle
in to find a way to have a new
conversation to be like I'm gonna take
this thing that I love and I'm gonna
[ __ ] try to make a living off of it
[ __ ]
live and die by your voice you know
that's what you bring to the table so
right the thing that you feel like this
is what I want to do even if people are
like yeah that like [ __ ] do it if it
ain't that one it's the next one but
here's the thing this is my position on
it you can't guarantee success beyond
anybody but yourself you could [ __ ]
make yourself so happy and make the
perfect movie for you and that is or
anything booked [ __ ] whatever song
[ __ ] blanket whatever your [ __ ]
make and you could make it perfect for
you to the point where you're like this
is exactly what I want it to be people
won't see it necessarily the same way
right you can't guarantee anyone's going
to show up or pay for it or whatever the
[ __ ] so in that world make it the thing
you want it to be because then at least
yours totally satisfying a hundred
percent one person the person will have
to live with it for the rest of their
[ __ ] lives because other people may
consume it move on to other [ __ ] but you
will carry it like [ __ ] herpes to the
grave so just make sure it's yours man
it says who you are because maybe it
works maybe it don't maybe it's [ __ ]
like maybe it's mall rats mall rats came
out and everyone was like [ __ ] you and
then 10 years later people like you're a
genius so it's like maybe you just
[ __ ] wait and it catches up at the
end of the day you did you so and and it
speaks volumes about who you are maybe
get you another job maybe people like
that movie was my favorite thing that
book was my favorite thing ever what
else are you [ __ ] doing or interested
in nothing bad ever came from from doing
your stuff you know what I'm saying from
trying to express your voice so do that
at all costs
that's my always my best advice
you know yeah for sure and after you do
that do it again and do it again and do
it again
I've always been making something you
know like the one thing you can do
especially if you're a writer that
doesn't need any money to do this [ __ ]
is keep going because the thing that
will happen is you'll get better at it
even if you're not trying to almost by
accident you will just make enough
mistakes along the way
to not make those mistakes to make new
ones then when just those new ones
you'll find a way to be better at the
thing you wanted to do iteration is what
it's all about
because yes there is there's absolutely
the people who have their one great
story to tell and tell it and then like
what do I do now like great the next one
then the next one because it's all about
the next one and if nobody buys the
first one nobody buys the second one
somebody's gonna buy the third one or
the fourth or the fifth one anything but
like hey you like that look at this
[ __ ] barn full of [ __ ] that I have
back here that I've been making well
been waiting for you to get right with
me you know it's always been doing it
always been getting better at it because
we always can be better at it and you
only do that not by reading books not by
listening to podcasts a little bit a
couple of them kind of cool but it's
been making the [ __ ] thing and so
keep making the thing you know even if
you're a filmmaker make the [ __ ]
thing if you're a podcast or make the
[ __ ] thing if you're writer make the
[ __ ] thing and make that thing true
to who you are I love it give it up
tomorrow that's one that's two what's
the third question the third one was I
think that most common book tropes have
been implemented in different movies
very well I think the Dark Knight is
probably one of the strongest examples
of how the hero and the villain are two
sides of the same coin
I think Richard Donner Superman is
probably the strongest origin story but
that idea of interconnected universe was
probably the most difficult because of
its complexity and now that we've had an
end game would you prefer
now going forward stories that involve
in Turkey
activity or would you still enjoy
self-contained what a great question
now that we've been spoiled by universes
how could you know what now that how do
you keep me down on the farm now that
I've seen Perry you know what I'm saying
like I know what's possible and in my
world when I was making movies as a kid
I connected them all because I'm like
why wouldn't you like this just makes
sense that they all know each other and
[ __ ] I'm telling all these stories I
want them all connected why because I
love comic books and that's what they
did in comic books and then when Marvel
started their cinematic universe people
were like they stole your idea and I was
like well no technically I stole their
idea from comic books and brought it
into movies and [ __ ] so I have always
loved the idea that like you're you know
the 90 minute to our investment of your
time and a standalone motion picture I
love it like that's what I was raised on
but connectivity like I like sequels and
always did as a kid always liked more
and liked when they would reference the
other one and not just you know in
overall like there's more [ __ ]
gremlins like when they make gremlins -
and then they [ __ ] make fun of Phoebe
Cates doing the sad my dad got caught in
a fire Blade where I'm like they're
aware of their [ __ ] movie like [ __ ]
like that so I love that kind of [ __ ] I
could still watch movies that absolutely
standalone but like you if you're
telling me like and you don't have to do
it like remember when Universal was
doing the dark universe and like we're
making a universe just like Marvel and
we're like good [ __ ] look you don't
have to tell me that's your intention at
the beginning but like if that's what
winds up happening like I always support
that in a world of preference I honestly
would love more interconnectivity I'm
not saying everything has to lead to an
end game in ship like that but like like
look one of my favorite movies to watch
over and over again and we used to watch
it like - go to sleep - me and my wife
the talented mr. Ripley which for the
first time I saw somebody was like
what'd you think I was like I don't know
it's
[ __ ] pretty people doing simple
things [ __ ] them and then I watched a
few thousand more times like it's like
oh it's much richer than that
but that was set in a world like based
on a series of books Patricia Highsmith
wrote so you could have kept [ __ ]
going you know what I'm saying and I
would have [ __ ] been like right there
Fletch that Chevy Chase movies I was
based on a series of books so they could
have kept going Fletch libs wasn't based
on any book whatsoever they went
original stuff so I loved knowing
there's more it feels like hook [ __ ] for
my investment in time cuz let's let's we
do invest time in these things you fall
in love with a god Emma that's why
sequels happen because people like I
[ __ ] love this [ __ ] so [ __ ] much
it's Studios like really would you pay
for more and then it took a long time
but like [ __ ] got artful about
sequels where the like yeah we're in
this for the money let's be honest like
we're not doing this for charity we're
not doing this to make you feel like a
kid again we're trying to make you feel
like a kid again because we want your
[ __ ] money and [ __ ] so it's all about
money we know that that being said can
it also be artful can it also be fun can
it also be [ __ ] can't you reward the
people who are coming again and again by
like giving him [ __ ] don't cost you
anything but time maybe dimes you know
like it maybe cost a few bucks to show
Captain America picking up that hammer
but most of the [ __ ] they do that makes
you happier a little gentle [ __ ]
callbacks just saying the same [ __ ]
line on your left
accompanied no special effect but the
reference of that line alone [ __ ]
brings you to tears and the movie too
you could do that if people are invested
in your characters in your world so I
would always I'm not saying like they'd
all better be connected and [ __ ] like
I've read the Bible and I've read Fletch
in Jesus and Fletch know each other like
I don't I don't need them all connected
but I in a world of preference I would I
do lean toward world building yeah you
know it's in my blood anyway as a
storyteller and as a fan it appeals to
me like no end I am like you but lesser
so only in that it's how I've always
thought of you in general
Alessa he's like me but lesser so is
that like make me a great [ __ ] movie
like first and foremost make me a great
movie that's hard enough like just
making one great [ __ ] Iron Man if
there were no more Iron Man's and we
just got Iron Man cool great
happy go home happy don't consider the
universe mandatory it's nice of it makes
sense sometimes I don't need it I don't
need the matrix two or three I just want
the first one yeah but when the first
one happened you loved it so much that
they were like we're doing to mourn
you're like [ __ ] yeah and then they
showed him you're like [ __ ] no how do
you ruin such an easy [ __ ] I'll
goddamn it
why is everyone [ __ ] in a cave yeah
you know it's like as much as I love you
know the Marvel Universe as much as I
love these stories that are deepen and
go on for a while I love the Iron Giant
I also just loved the one great movie
that could give me a sequel I don't ever
need a suit that's so sad like could you
imagine that one day somebody was like
Iron Giant - you'd be like get the [ __ ]
out of here I've been waiting for that
because the head and the pieces were
coming together at the end of that movie
but I don't need it like I have all for
the discrete slab of culture that you
can just ingest on its own and have it
be great and move on from it you know
Hollywood is out of that business
otherwise you know there would be a lot
more inceptions I think you know the
giant hundred million dollar brand new
piece of IP that we're never gonna make
a sequel of just cuz it's cool there's a
friend of mine who is pitching like
crazy right now and he went into a few
places including legendary and the
people of legendary were like look we're
just be honest with you we don't really
do original ideas here we do IP like
yeah you know you got Batman we're
[ __ ] on board you got a story that
nobody's ever heard before
that's cute [ __ ] off you know like they
want [ __ ] that's they're in the business
of making [ __ ] that's [ __ ] known and
you know it's a funny story to tell but
it is kind of troubling on a level of
being a creative person who doesn't have
access to major IP it's like well how
the [ __ ] am I gonna make a look
one day yeah you know in some of the the
movies that are our favorite movies ever
our one in Dunn's you know your
inceptions your sucking you know the
departed six cents like just tell me a
great story and let's be done with it
you know I'm like the sixth sense
honestly does not need to be part of the
universe in night Shyamalan not
everything needs to connect because
sometimes when you connect it you're
forcing connections that don't belong
you know I have to be fair like I like
the fact that he back to her universe
that movie and like to his credit he
made like unbreakable at a time where
comic book movies were limping a little
bit like I believe that was a post
Batman and Robin movie when people were
like comic book movies so he was really
like waving the flag and if that movie
had been more successful I think he
would went into it like right away but
then he went on a very interesting
journey with his career and then arrived
at a place where he's like you know what
I was I was doing something a few
minutes ago I'm gonna go back to doing
it in a few minutes just happened to be
like 10 15 [ __ ] years so I was happy
that he got to kind of go back that
being said I loved unbreakable I still
haven't seen split and I still haven't
watched glass and like every time I'm
about to watch it on iTunes with my wife
at night I'm like glass she's like what
else is on and then we wind up doing
something else so I'll get to it about
she just not as into a design but I'll
get to it eventually but what I didn't I
didn't get to go see that was busy and
[ __ ] but like I support the idea and
obviously I'm taking five minutes to
defend the guy about doing it but like I
still haven't seen it but I love that he
[ __ ] decided to go back and you know
he wasn't too proud to be like you know
what I was gonna do something and then I
get distracted by [ __ ] Mel Gibson and
signs and now I'm gonna go back and
finish what I was [ __ ] doing yeah so
like yeah I'm all for universe when it
makes sense but I'm also all for the
discreet just like he was a thing it's
wonderful it's perfect it's two hours
long it is taking you on a ride and
you're happy that it's over because it
ended where it needed and every story
needs an ending and not every story
needs to have that at maybe 22 hours
late
part of the journey is the end yeah I
heard that in a movie man it was good I
guess maybe I were you raised Christian
Catholic or anything like that
now it's raised on Looney Tunes so was i
but I I think that has a lot to do with
it man like the Bible is one big ongoing
story in which everybody kind of knows
each other and [ __ ] like that it's kind
of like a comic book that's why I was so
comfortable with comic books because I'm
like oh he's just like Jesus but he's
got a better outfit you know she'll like
it
so I I don't know I guess I'm programmed
for for the long con I mean if I was
raised Catholic I was definitely
programmed for the long con but but that
being said I I do enjoy law like [ __ ]
connected I know what you're saying it's
true they could stand alone and stuff
but I don't know I I wonder if it's like
if it's based more on love of comic
books or based more in being raised in a
faith which is a bunch of like superhero
stories or I just like what I like just
like what you like they think so yeah is
because like sports didn't work out I
had Shepard Fairey came over and didn't
never feel like I'm name dropping a lot
but in order to tell the story I got to
say Shepard Fairey came over and did an
episode of SModcast and he told this
fascinating story about like he was a
young sports kid and was in all these
[ __ ] like sports competitive [ __ ]
then he busted his leg and he couldn't
play so he wasn't like he was a guy get
picked first all the time so then while
he was busted not a commission he found
out like nobody gave a [ __ ] about him
anymore and he was like 9 so at age nine
he became like nihilistic as [ __ ] and
[ __ ] cuz he was just like oh I see the
game now nobody gives a [ __ ]
and so he likes sports but he hated
people because of that so he's like what
sport can I play by myself and he found
skateboarding and so in skateboarding he
found a culture of people similar and
whatnot and then he like drawn and [ __ ]
and doing cutouts and meaghan stickers
he made that Andre the Giant has a posse
and that led to obey and that led to his
entire [ __ ] career and I was talking
to him and I was like hey man if you
don't [ __ ] bust your leg maybe you
don't become Shepard Fairey and he's
like probably not I probably wouldn't be
playing baseball and [ __ ] so [ __ ]
crazy the Turner screw is based on
something so like something that in the
moment was like oh my god he busted his
leg this [ __ ] ruins everything and
then down the road it's like that was
the key that was the bridge and [ __ ] you
never know what its gonna be
regardless now I'm [ __ ] along with you
those were great questions you [ __ ]
win man rishabh you get stickers you got
shirt pleasure thank you for the goddamn
kind words alright Jay see what else we
got hey what's your name what is it like
banana [ __ ] I like banana everyone give
it up for Shannon like banana how are
you what can we do you [ __ ] um first of
all I'll just thank you I bought this
ticket specifically so I could be here
tonight to hear you talk about endgame
and it wasn't until you've talked about
it that I actually cried
remembering the scene and I didn't pee
on myself yeah how did everyone do with
the bathroom breaks on that movie that's
good yeah I don't give a [ __ ] hell that
I clenched the whole time pretty much
yeah I know some people it's like an
issue and [ __ ] like they're putting out
articles that we kind of came out and
when do you break and I'm like have
y'all never sat for three I don't pee
when I'm at work I just like to wear a
[ __ ] diaper
hey man and we're in a [ __ ] you're
supposed to reuse everything in this new
culture [ __ ] reuse the popcorn bucket
take a piss in it right there that being
said what do you want I decided to do a
combo Game of Thrones and game question
since the women are the only one on Game
of Thrones currently who aren't useless
if you could cast any of the women from
Game of Thrones
in the MCU going forward who would you
have for what role and why so I was
thinking like Maisie Sophie Lina Amelia
I mean are we casting actresses or the
characters from Game of Thrones
actresses all right so I can't be like
Aria starker she would have killed
Thanos quick the [ __ ] three hours we
would have been home in an hour
like I thought Emilia Clarke would be a
great Sue Storm oh I see what you're
playing now I want to play you're gay
yes I like it it's like when you watch
jeopardy and you don't understand the
category until somebody gets it right
you're like oh I could do that begin
with cute do you know you want to love
jeopardy let me see all right I got one
go you go Maisie Williams as Kitty Pryde
oh that's [ __ ] good all right let me
think
Marvel mhm x-men don't count because
they just got because they just joined a
oh okay but that was perfect never mind
there we go whenever I got I can dig my
own rules okay let me see who is uh [ __ ]
she's in us another ex person I want to
stay away from the ex universe Oh
Cersei was named Lena Headey mm-hmm Sue
Storm I mean let her play against type
why does she have to be a [ __ ]
uber-bitch everyone wants to die again
let her be the opposite of that like do
something else it's not a sexy answer
but I'm sticking by
got another one in you oh my god you
want more I'm just I'm just still
thinking cuz that went so quick I was
yeah alright [ __ ] who plays Sansa
sophie Turner what if she played Jean
Grey that'd be amazing
well I'm sorry I I just got back from us
five-year snap so I might have missed
something yes that's part of the problem
the mobile universe is that although
where there was that that moment that
great moment where all those women
banded together in the movie is that
getting that love or hate on the
internet I it's it's divisive really
yeah it's the people who feel like it's
pandering and then there's people like
well [ __ ] yeah why would we not want
this the whole movies pandering like
it's fanservice to the highest degree in
[ __ ] like that so that fits huh that's
very on Brian for it to be pandering I
thought it was a cool moment yeah was
out for it
do you remember I can't remember who it
was a Grant Morrison's new x-men run
there was this like this old lady I want
to say was like somebody's mom I can't
remember who it was remember that
character she was in the [ __ ] wait what
was this when Grant Morrison was writing
the x-men yes there was some like
elderly female character who I want to
say was like not Magneto's mom because
that would have been too easy but it was
something oh you're right
yes yes who said that excellent oh my
holy [ __ ] deep cuts Paul well done yeah
so so Catelyn Stark as that later that's
a good one too yeah whatever Catelyn
Stark's real name is I don't know any
names like I just know the face of that
lady in the face lady she's gonna play I
didn't know we could use dead Game of
Thrones people as well hmm it doesn't
change my answer
ooh Natalie Dormer is Emma Frost
oh my god well Lena Headey would be a
good Emma Frost actually that's a little
typecasting a bit but Gwendoline
Christie Christie Brienne Gwendoline
Christie Kraven the hunter but it's
Craven with two N's internee Craven
[ __ ] awesome man what a great poll
and she gets to play a villain as
opposed to like a hero this time oh my
god you're on fire I like all your
answers no your Sansa Stark is a nice
[ __ ] Jean Grey was great that was
just witty what a great question it got
great answer you win tickets give it up
for Allen's Ellen all right JC line us
up another victim we have two sets of
tickets left what's your name good
friend my name is Brian Brian everyone
give it up for Brian thank you what can
we do you for Brian my question was with
the new Disney streaming app and them
announcing a Watchers themed an animated
series if you guys could take one moment
or a specific movie from the MCU and do
a what-if scenario which would it be
hold on I'm gonna they're doing a
Watchers they're doing all the what-if
cartoons yeah yeah so gonna use the
watchers than that I guess they must
right yes watu was always like the guy
going what if all right so the question
is what if movie if you could just do an
episode of that show featuring one
moment or movie from the MCU what would
be the scenario okay great question
number one you want to go first or go
first okay what if old man cat gave the
shield to Bucky instead of sand
I don't know what that story is because
I haven't told me yet but there's
totally a world in which that that is
that choice that's good okay what if
they put a sign on that little boy at
the funeral so that so that we all knew
who he was
when we watched the movie and gave him
his proper [ __ ] just like hello my name
is dad I just would have taken hello I
was in hired Man 3 the board the boy
from Iron Man 3 let me see what if what
is what Marvel what if would I like to
see the dark world didn't suck good pull
they reclaimed it with end game you
can't make that joke anymore let me see
what if what if
Iron Man didn't I mean this is like I
don't have a one-liner but what if Iron
Man you know his experience didn't make
him go heroic instead it made him go
Doctor Doom like he was just like [ __ ]
these people [ __ ] they imprison be [ __ ]
this world and he built an iron suit and
punished everybody in [ __ ] that's kinda
like though dark I know right DC dark
not me more DC's [ __ ] life man
I still have not wow I will see I
haven't seen it I've been busy
I've been busy watching end game a
couple thousand times yes I will go see
everyone I know absolutely loves the
movie and they keep telling me like
you're gonna [ __ ]
love this you especially so I do
definitely look hard but they've become
much happier [ __ ] Vilnius between
that and Aquaman under the sea become
Daffy yeah it's a bit Daffy
all right that's me what do you get I
already went I did the [ __ ] I did
Bucky gets the shield oh yeah that's
right you went first I did you came
later I did I came second I'm [ __ ] we
did them both that was a great question
you [ __ ] win come get your [ __ ] god
damn pleasure man thank you all right JC
our last question of the night hold on
whoever put this up here is this meant
to be signed or do we keep this please
sign it who move yours thank you
wait what's your name I'm Gabe Gabe give
it up for gay hi
welcome sir what can we do for me I just
wanted to say thank you I'm sure like
everybody else in here just thank you
for whatever you do I'm here doing what
I'm doing in Los Angeles because of you
too so thank you for that so my question
is Kevin you did a Batman and Green
Hornet crossover with your other
podcasting partner Ralph Garman yes so
we just to be fair I've said many times
but I'm going to say it one more time
again that is largely Ralph like ralph
was the genius on that project I was
very much shotgun ralph loves Batman 66
so when we got the job I was just like
hey man I'm gonna bring my friend Ralph
Garman in because like he knows this
world better than me and they were like
go ahead and then I brought my friend in
and it was like All About Eve because he
just pushed me the [ __ ] out
but I always like to make sure that he
gets full credit for that my name is on
the book and I did a little bit but like
that was Ralph's baby and I wished he'd
kept [ __ ] going cuz he was really good
thank you
well here's the the redo question so if
you had the opportunity to do a comic
book with Marc what would it be a mark
if you had the opportunity to partner up
with Kevin on a comic book which one
would you choose so any any universe it
could be image to be dark horse could be
DC could be Marvel anything what would
you guys choose to do with each other
whoo thank you yeah what do we talk
about that good because we're never
gonna do it yeah and also he's out of
the job right are you talking about the
the letter okay we could tell that we
can tell another story - we could do
that - we can tell all right you know
what it's a great question thank you
you're definitely gonna win especially
because you're gonna get out of this two
stories that III don't you've never told
yeah and I know I've never told the
other one okay all right this is sexy
yes all right so here's two things that
we almost worked on together you go
first
I can't remember the number of the
podcast but it was early on in the run
we were still talking about [ __ ]
Gotham that's how early in
when it was which by the way Gotham just
came to an end that should have been in
our news no big finale I should have
watched it but I didn't yeah they didn't
come to a big close and and apparently
there was a Batman you and Batman made
an appearance and stuff I mean and they
you know they've they built themselves a
wonderful little continuity over a
course of five years over there an
achievement a stunning achievement but I
understand somebody told me that could
never say they couldn't call that
character the Joker because they weren't
allowed to because the Joker belongs to
the Batman movies just like they
couldn't where I don't think they said
Batman and Gotham because Batman belongs
to the movies so they showed him but
they couldn't is interesting when I look
through through that prism I was like oh
my god because of the way it's licensed
okay yeah so we were talking about
Gotham back when we watch Gotham and we
went off in this tangent about the the
the culpability of Alfred in the
creation of who Bruce Wayne is because
Bruce Wayne probably doesn't become
Batman if he's still like a young
[ __ ] kid who's broken his parents die
and Alfred says you know what you need
son you need some mental help like you
need to talk to some meet a shrink you
need a psychiatrist you need somebody to
help you deal with this massive grief
and guilt that you're feeling over the
last year panel you have you you're
traumatized yes having seen your parents
murdered in well maybe they shouldn't
have gone down a [ __ ] road called
Crime Alley but still you know they got
killed that hurts a little boy's feeling
right and it's a little boy who thinks
that it's his fault because it's a
little boy who wanted to leave the
theater and if he doesn't want to leave
the theater then everybody's still
[ __ ] alive in which continuity is
this Tim Burton Batman Batman Begins to
heaven begins - oh that's right he's
just like errant he's scared anymore Stu
leave and so his parents take him out of
the theater and then he the parents died
that's not comics though that was never
really a part of it even in Frank
Miller's version when he did like Dark
Knight or no when they did year 1 and
stuff but yeah I did like that aspect
it's nice little tweak but whether you
want that part of the guilt or not it's
still the kid dealing with grief you
imagine it's [ __ ] tough enough like
this characters
hard enough like I watched my parents
die in a dirty alley and then like 50
years later some guys just like yeah and
it's your fault you little piece of [ __ ]
because you want to leave the theater so
this was this was going to be a
four-part sort of series of like graphic
novel EPS I guess you would have called
it where the first part is about that
night it's about the night where I
offered us to go to the police station
and pick up young Bruce and what he says
and what he does and that we treats that
kid the second part is Bruce sort of
being walling himself in Wayne Manor
like he doesn't go to school he doesn't
interact with anybody he used to be a
friend like he's just turned entirely
inwardly and Alfred unwilling to let
that boy heal like he heals broken he
doesn't get him help you doesn't have
somebody sit down and say listen Bruce
it's not your fault listen Bruce it'll
be okay listen Bruce this happens to
everybody and it turns out nobody else
turns into a [ __ ] Cape Crusader Bruce
there's a way through this the third
chapter would have been just alfred
living in wayne manor when it's all
[ __ ] covered in drapes and [ __ ] while
young Bruce is off in his year in the
wild like learning kung fu when learning
crime-fighting techniques and all that
[ __ ] and they like did I did I push this
boy away did I not do enough and then
the last chapter is Alfred and Bruce
Wayne Google and Bruce is like coming
back from every night out as Batman
going out every night is to be Batman
and the steady guilt of I did this to
this boy like every time I patch him up
I am trying to patch up my own guilt
over not having gotten him the care that
he needed
Batman is my fault and I have to live
with it every [ __ ] day so it was the
tragedy of Alfred really brilliant
brilliant
and and like we didn't even like we sat
on it for a little while okay well we
should just [ __ ] like call a dude and
see if we can get something done like we
know guys who work at DC some of which
run DC and and and it just never really
got any traction over there and then
ironically they announced like an Alfred
Pennyworth TV show they were like yeah
we don't think I'll fruit is enough of a
sell I'm like but the [ __ ] are
gonna spend like eighty million dollars
making an offer TV show and you don't
want to spend like 10 grand to make an
Alfred comic book cuz you don't mean
there's a market for it okay okay but
yeah that was that was I think the first
one that we were like hey we could this
there's something here there's something
else that wasn't in comic book form and
I think it's it's I guess it's safe to
talk about because it's like just dead
no chance of it ever happening years ago
Jeff Jones was on fat man on Batman and
we talked about like we're working on
something because we were there was a
period where I was going over to DC
every day and we were sitting down in
this giant room that had walls that were
whiteboards they could just [ __ ]
write on him and [ __ ] and that's where
they sit down and just map out things
and ideas and sure other TV shows do it
that was new to me first time I walked
in I was like you could write on these
walls this is just like me in high
school this is awesome so we would sit
there and cram and build and we came up
with a ten episode series arguments
going back three years at this point
maybe four if you find that Geoff Johns
episode
whenever Geoff was on that's when we
were doing this we were building a
series that we did take out to pitch to
a couple places based on the question
and it was fraught with peril because
the questions nobody's quite sure who
owns the question there's some weird
issues with its ownership because they
came from the charlton characters that
DC bought but it may not they may not be
able to use them in medium beyond print
it's it's just very complicated because
for years I've been talking to Warner
Brothers whenever they're like hey man
do you want to do something that you
love the superhero [ __ ] what do you want
to do and each time I was always like
the only one I'd really be interested in
doing is the question because I think
it's just [ __ ] terrifying
like if you're in an alley and you're
committing some crime and somebody's
like hey and you turn around it's got
just like Batman you like if you
somebody goes hey and you turn around
and there's no [ __ ] face and [ __ ] you
just piss your pants that's [ __ ]
terrifying and stuff so I was like I
think that'd be a cool new Irish film so
for a while we couldn't make it work in
movies because they didn't know who
owned the character and and I remember
had something to do with Watchmen as
well they member they said we're having
a bit of a problem with Watchmen because
watchman has Rorschach and Rorschach is
based on the question so there was even
a weird legal entanglement there so it
wound up kind of going away but the
series that we mapped out was [ __ ]
dope I'm a question fan so like there
was a high bar and I wasn't working
alone I was working with him and this
guy porn sack who's really [ __ ] great
but we came up with this wicked cool
show we went to Warner horizon to pitch
it that was their like video division or
whatever the [ __ ] and then you'd sell it
to a streamer nowadays you just go right
into the [ __ ] streamer or honestly
you'd probably go to the DC Universe app
at this point right so we went out to
Warner horizon and they kind of dug the
idea and stuff and then the who owns the
character entered the picture and then
it just kind of dissipated and fell
apart but mark and I were going to be
working on that is always there a
question storyline that we should all
read now that it was kind of based on or
was it totally whole cloth news story
but using all the familiar elements and
stuff and it was Vic sage hub city whole
problem
it was Vic sage like that's why I think
Greg Rucka and Vince Renee Montoya so
they're like listen we have to be able
to do the question is too [ __ ] awesome
we can't do Vic sage so let me invent a
brand new character who now will and the
complete rights to and can do in movies
and TV and animation and everything ya
know we were stuck with [ __ ] damn it's
cool sorry
never gonna happen that's so weird
that's why they invented the Montoya
quest I think that there was there was a
there was an interest in being able to
put the quest
back into into into play you know how
that's [ __ ] fascinating yeah do you
know they there's a the I'm sure most
people especially watching this show
would know this but the yellow oval that
surrounds you know Batman's bat on his
Chester did for most of my life and went
away for a bit but it looks like it
might be coming back yeah I read
something in a Detective Comics 1000
about that yeah yes good story I liked
it that's a very good story short
mercifully short guy didn't make Batman
piss his pants so I was a okay with that
story but that yellow only exists
because DC wanted to trademark a bat
symbol and they couldn't Batman
traditionally just had a black bat on
his chest you can't trademark that
because that's just a picture of a bat
nobody can own that but the moment they
put the yellow around it
that was trademark Abel so Batman only
has that on his chest because DC was
like we want to [ __ ] own that we want
to be able to make money off it and then
the writers were told make this [ __ ]
work and then they were like alright
he's got a yellow oval on his chest and
[ __ ] and then it wasn't for 20 more
years before Frank Miller was like you
know why he's got that oval on his chest
why it's yellow because it's a [ __ ]
target and he's got a metal plate under
there and suddenly you're like that's
[ __ ] bad-ass
so a very creative talent took a very
business decision and made it a very
important wonderful touching part of the
mythos and shoe why did I tell that
story everybody now I love those kind of
mercenary slash like inspiration stories
do you know that there are lyrics to the
Star Trek theme zone I remember yes and
I know the the last lyrics are you know
remember remember me it's awful the only
reason the only reason there are lyrics
to that song is because Alexander
courage who wrote that original Star
Trek theme was set to make a hundred
percent of the proceeds once you sell
that music to Records we're gonna cut a
soundtrack you get the money
jean-robert was like you know what I can
get 50% of that by writing lyrics to
that song I suddenly I gotta put my name
on this to lyrics nobody will ever
[ __ ] hear and now I get 50% of the
publishing rights to this song so
obscene Roddenberry was less Kirk and
more calm as what you're saying
you just he stole half of elux into
courage and star trek money Wow
wow man I mean I'm one level I'm sure
he's like a man without my show you
don't get any [ __ ] theme whatsoever
yeah welcome to Hollywood [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's wild you know what don't wait did
you answer I answer did you answer uh
yeah I did Alfred
we both answered excellent question you
win the last tickets man why'd you man
[Applause]
my god is that if we run out of news and
run out of questions what time is it
10:51 it's impossible to do this show
any any shorter than two and a half
hours it's so [ __ ] up but I love it
and I'll tuck in I would do the show for
[ __ ] five hours and [ __ ] one night we
got to try that to see how many people
last it's us and [ __ ] these five and
that's [ __ ] it no not tonight man
it's time to [ __ ] go home and [ __ ]
boy oh boy I love doing it though you
have a good time I had a blast
this gentleman do you have a good time
[Applause]
it it can be a horrible sick old world
out there sometimes but whenever and
we're in this place gathered together in
this church and it always everything
feels like it's gonna work out
so like was it they kept saying like
Tony says to his dad he's like
everything's gonna work out yeah and
pepper didn't she said it to him to at
the end think everything's gonna work
out you can rest now yeah everything's
gonna work out man all right
I love this podcast 3,000 yes yes well
said the the show is that men ladies and
gentlemen but don't forget Star Wars day
may the fourth right here at scum and
villainy this is a place if you're on
the west coast you want to be here man
it's it's cramped clickbait here you get
free shirts with dick pics on them it's
gonna be [ __ ] bad if you're on the
East Coast go to Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash I'll be sitting there
signing and [ __ ] like that on may the
4th which is may the 4th isn't it thank
you
[ __ ] I mean we are a comic book show
we should talk about that this weekend
coming up folks is Free Comic Book Day
so if you want to bring a friend or a
kid or a friend's kid just make sure you
know the kid to the to a commission
ticket yeah don't just grab a kid off
the street that's illegal but bring them
to the comic book store and get some
free comics into their hands and not
just kids into the hands of adults as
well and stuff no better time to walk
into a comic book store than this
weekend and try something new yeah but
that being said boy I've had a [ __ ]
blast mez nice to kick back and talk
about like things that you love deeply
with people like I feel you I feel you
man like I don't think I'll ever get
tired of talking about endgame
you know what I'm saying and I know it's
really and we've just seen it and [ __ ]
but like it was nice to sit here tonight
I loved hearing your [ __ ] take on I'm
like you're right it is about that I'm
so stupid I just thought it was about
money and they made all of it I'm gonna
give them a little more of mine I'm
definitely gonna see at least two more
times that they can appeal I think
you'll see it one more time three was
enough for it
three three was three was good until you
get home did I get home or until I get
back to my house I'm like we can go
another time yeah it was pretty good no
doubt I'll be honest with you man no you
shouldn't be saying this sort of [ __ ]
but like Friday night that had opened I
couldn't get tickets to see it because
they were [ __ ] sold out and [ __ ] so I
was going on Saturday morning so Friday
night I sat up on YouTube because
somebody in some foreign country was
putting up clips from [ __ ] from
endgame and I'd already seen it so I'm
like I'm in the clear and I couldn't
like I couldn't [ __ ] believe it like
I'm sitting there going no this must be
fake I must be like some Russian is
watching me right now or something like
that but it was legit [ __ ] clips from
the movie and I was like holy [ __ ] and
then Disney was pulling him down as fast
as they were going up so it was this
race against time I'm like no no I just
wanna see the whole snap oh [ __ ] they
took it off pretty [ __ ] amazing then
I went I went I went opening night
Thursday night at the ArcLight in
Sherman Oaks with a bunch of blurred
'he's familiar with the blurred bunch of
black nerds and and
and so there's this little like very
very familiar with blurred familiar with
the blurbs on your left and uh and and
one of these blurbs in this group was
event nicole brown we end up the blurred
queen of the blurred and so well his
queen of the blurbs she said this yeah
she'll Nichols she's still the reigning
Empress but so where she's like we got
to get in it's 9:45 you gotta get the
movies gonna start we're gonna get in
there well why are you so [ __ ]
agitated event we're gonna be fine we
got to get in there and so we sit there
and watching the movie and and suddenly
like Captain America gets in this
elevator and then and can't believe hi
and we're alike cuz she's sitting like
what and then there's a minute where
you're like is that event or is that
like a black lady who looks like a vet
if that's the case does it get like a
racist if we're like that made him look
just like you look it's me [ __ ]
I'm in the movie and so just this weird
little pocket of like she kept this
secret for like two and a half years cuz
she shot it two years ago are you
[ __ ] me yeah she thought it was
gonna be an infinity war and so she went
they would see that movies that I cut
out of the movie I guess oh well and
then she comes and maybe I'm in this and
maybe I'm in this one and she didn't
know when she didn't know where she must
have been terrified of that NDA to keep
that choir for to plug into [ __ ]
years Wow and just there's a little like
ripple in this pocket of the theater
everybody's [ __ ] applauding and the
event Nicole Brown the elevator like
what's so funny she's living the dream
the [ __ ] dream she's 1970s SHIELD
agent
Jesus I love that sequence because I
can't believe I always reminds me of -
my favorite scenes in marvel movies one
is when Tommy Lee Jones throws the
grenade on the ground and [ __ ]
everyone scatters except for Steve the
wimpy Steve jumps on it's beautiful
[ __ ] scene and then in Winter Soldier
when him in and Black Widow go to the
Emile Zola scene is [ __ ] just
spellbinding it feels like a James Bond
movie and [ __ ] as he explains his plan
he's like you are sitting in my brain
captain like all that [ __ ] is like oh my
god so when they went back again for
this movie when they met back to camp
Lee hi it was Camp Lee hi which is in
New Jersey and Stan's final cameo yeah
this Stan yes
freezin by in a car with an upset bumper
sticker on it and he's with a girl who I
believe is meant to be Joanie I've seen
it twice now and a Mike holy [ __ ] that
looks like young a picture of young
Joanie and stuff that he wants to show
me so I I think it's a little deeper
than just like it's Stan driving around
with a girl I think it's meant to be
Stan's girl which is really [ __ ]
beautiful
but that sequence takes place in New
Jersey camp Lehigh in 1970 that's when I
was [ __ ] born [ __ ] so as I was
watching the movie I was like I'm alive
now and then I remembered I'm part of
the Marvel Universe thanks to Captain
Marvel so it's all [ __ ] good yes it
is humble brag humble brag ah ladies and
gentlemen have you got a good time this
evening I can't thank you enough for
coming out but there is no show without
the man standing next to me give it up
for the fabulous mr. mark barnard Eddie
thank you they can thank you and that is
fat man beyond for this week I'm Kevin
Smith I am walk with our tune in next
time same bat-time same bat-channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you